Four three,
two,
one.
Robin Black Gentleman.
What's up buddy?
Hey man,
it's great to see you.
Are you fresh back from Singapore?
I am,
yeah,
I was in Singapore like 48 hours ago.
Did they make that special shiny silver one for you?
Because that looks like this design for you know it's,
I mean,
yeah,
it does Kinda look like it's designed for me,
which is why I wanted that.
Yeah,
it's a rock and roll.
One Championship.
One AFC championship.
So what's it like over there man?
Let me explain to everybody.
One FC is like the Asian version of the UFC.
It's a gigantic organization that has been going on for how long now?
Yeah,
2011 so solid seven years and really high level fights over there.
Amazing,
amazing fight.
Singapore itself is wild.
So I went over there to chat with them.
So chat tree,
city of tongue,
Robinson and he and I had been chatting and,
and I love kind of how they see martial arts.
So they don't call it even fc anymore.
It's just one championship.
They don't even use the word fighting.
Really.
It's martial arts.
And the way I see it and the way I studied martial arts and share it is an art
form like painting or yoga or you know,
things,
things of that nature.
Less spectacle.
That's always how I've seen it and I was how I love it and that's how they see
it and that's how they present it.
And that's,
it's presented from this sort of inspirational own your history kind of way in
Asia.
And that was what attracted me to them right away.
I mean it's,
it's definitely an art form.
It's values based,
like they're kind of seeking to inspire people through these athletes and
artists.
It's pretty fucking cool.
So what,
what's motivating them to take this a sort of radical approach?
So it's wild that you say that because to me this is the approach.
So I think what we do or the way that we presented in North America is radical.
I think martial arts is an art form.
Martial arts is this inspiring thing.
I mean you take,
say for example on loud song,
he is there 185 pound and 205 pound champion.
He's from me and Mar,
they have never had a world champion in any sport ever in their history.
I don't think they've had a gold medalist in the Olympics.
They've never had that.
This guy's a two division champion that will,
and that when I talked to [inaudible] about it and he was talking sort of about
why he sees it this way and why he's proud to present it this way.
He's like,
he knows without question that there are kids.
And he won his 205 pound title in me and mark in a stadium in Myanmar and he
said,
he knows without question there's a kid in,
they're going to become a lawyer one day because of that.
And they can feel it and it's real.
It's not like,
it's not like a marketing strategy.
Like this is how they see martial arts and it's how martial arts is viewed in
Asia.
Martial arts,
I get to travel so much now it's viewed different in Russia.
It's few different in Brazil.
Hello?
Viewed in Russia.
Russia is wild man.
I
got to work for uh,
ACB,
you know,
ACB.
Yeah.
Not Organization,
big organizations.
So in Russia it's very masculine and it's about about victory and about showing
your power and your strength and it really,
and,
and Russia is like that,
you know,
it's a reflection kind of of Russia.
Yeah.
Um,
the martial art thing,
I absolutely agree with you on that.
It is an art form,
but I also think it's a fight like Gilbert Melendez versus Diego Sanchez.
Yup.
That's an art form.
But it's a fight that was,
that was a fucking wild fight.
And there's no way that's just art.
That's,
that's art and a fight.
It's both things.
Is that a fight is hard.
It's a way.
It is in a way.
It's an expression of your personality,
your individuality.
It's heart.
Your fearlessness.
100% but it's a fight.
I'm not scared of the word fight.
No,
I'm not
like,
I like it.
I like that word.
But it is an art form.
Yes.
Fights are art.
Yes,
definitely.
I mean like Anderson Silva's second fight with shale son,
the way he landed that need of the body on the ground with that is just art.
That's art,
you know?
I mean,
if you,
you go back to Leo Machida just landing that front kick on Vitor Belfort,
that's our into is,
it's especially for someone who practices
martial arts,
you see the beauty in that you're like,
ah,
it's like a flower blossoming or sunrise or just something perfect.
The impossibility of it is what's so beautiful.
Like these guys are so unwilling partners and they have such like a desire to
accomplish what they want to accomplish.
To kick that guy in the face from that position with Victoria has a lifetime of
this,
a lifetime of being able to not let you do that and for you to first be willing
to be free enough to try it,
you know,
and,
and to,
to express it in that moment.
It is definitely hard,
but I,
I'm with you.
Fight doesn't intimidate me at all.
You know,
a fight is a beautiful thing.
A fight is we fight for things all the time.
You know,
it's a metaphor for life itself when you fight.
I think
bull rightly so,
are concerned with the idea of violence against someone who's an unwilling
participant.
And that's how they think of fighting.
They think of it as this thing that they want nothing to do with.
They don't want any violence in their life.
They don't want anybody to hurt them.
And I completely understand that.
I understand that position.
But that's not what it is.
When it's a competition.
I mean,
I,
it's a tired expression because I've said it too many times,
but my perception of what fighting is is high level problem solving with dire
physical consequences.
Yes.
Time.
And then the physical consequences are what make it so special.
You know?
No question,
no question.
Times make the good times better,
you know,
and the,
the,
the possibility that bad things can happen to you and do sometimes happen even
to the great ones,
you know,
I mean,
you see great fighters had been KOD and come back and you know,
there's,
that's a,
there's something about that where you realize like,
hey,
even fade or it can get knocked out.
You know what I mean?
Hey,
even,
you know,
Anderson Silva can get play cocky and get caught by that.
Chris Weidman left hook.
I mean,
this is just,
this is just the game
and you know,
I think in Asia in particular,
but there's different pockets of,
of how these this is viewed and how the philosophy of,
of connecting to martial arts and fighting is viewed.
And in Asia you would see a certain amount of the fighters would see being
losing badly is,
uh,
opportunity,
a chance because to come back and win again or to come back and show that you're
able and you,
you were given the gift of trying and failing.
You know what I mean?
Do you know you man,
you know?
Yeah.
That's a great way to approach it.
It's a great way to look at it.
You know what I mean?
That there really is a lesson that the average person can take in their life.
Like every time a person does have a bad thing happen to them,
it's an that dead terrible feelings and opportunity to rise from the ashes.
Yeah.
And winning when it's,
when you're just winning at everything.
And things come easily to you that I'm sure it still feels good,
but when you've gone through really hard times or when you've been challenged by
something or do you drop lower,
the high of the success is so much higher.
It's so much of a longer journey.
Personally,
when we've spoke before and when we talked about cm punk,
when he was fighting the first time,
I was like,
this is stupid.
You know,
and this guy is,
is pushing,
stacking himself into a position to try to not fail by making the challenge so
difficult that even if he fails,
you don't really,
but this is fully different now,
but now I'm,
I'm cheering for him because he was humiliated like he was.
He didn't just fail.
He was humiliated.
He,
he in front of everybody was shown to be,
you know,
people would judge them as weak or people the judgment that he would feel his
bad and he sat,
I'll go do it again.
He,
we are now in a completely different context because that's a guy who epically
failed in front of everybody and then dealt with that and now says,
I will try the journey again and this will make me a better person and I now I
fully endorse this,
I'm cheering for him.
Well,
he's now fighting a fighter who's commensurate in talent and there's nothing
wrong with being a beginner in martial arts,
but there's something wrong with thinking that you can be a beginner and fight
Micky gall big time.
Absolutely.
It was a foolish venture and I,
I,
I wa my approach to it was this is going to be a very good lesson for people
that are fans of positive thinking and they think that's enough.
That shit is not enough.
If you weigh 110 pounds,
you get positive.
Think your way to the bank.
Frances and Ganos still gonna Punch your brains out.
There's just no way around it.
And a guy who has really very little experience in martial arts and has
rudimentary control of his body.
I mean,
that's what I saw when I saw him training.
When I saw him training,
I was like,
oh my God,
he's getting killed
in that context.
And I,
but he belongs here.
Yeah.
And that's,
and everything's contextual.
Like,
just because I thought that was stupid.
It was stupid.
But that doesn't mean in this context,
I can't look and go.
There's a guy who didn't need to,
he doesn't need to come back.
He doesn't need to try again.
He doesn't need to go into the gym.
And I've been there.
You're in the gym and everyone's gone out,
man.
You did.
You did good.
I didn't do guy fucking failed miserably in front of everybody.
And then show up there cleaning the mats and work really hard and said,
I'm going to try it again.
Uh,
and yes,
that fight still him and this guy still should take place somewhere else.
Oh,
a hundred percent sure.
I mean,
shouldn't even be on the Tuesday night contender show.
No,
no.
It shouldn't.
Should be in some amateur event somewhere because that's really what they are
there.
They're guys learning how to compete.
Yeah.
Um,
during the first fight in the paper view.
Yeah,
that's fucking crazy.
But that has nothing to do with them.
That is a reflection on the company that's on a perception on,
on the choices that the machine makes.
Um,
and we also gave them a juicy contract.
Yes,
make that valid or viable right to make money off it.
But that again,
I think it makes,
it makes it deeper and harder and more chances to fail epically and,
and I lost twice in a row and then still want it to fight again and still
because it,
I really want it to,
and,
and it was important to me and it meant something to me and I was going to
change as a human being by doing it.
And I was ridiculed.
I can relate to what he's going through,
but I did it on a little show and in Winnipeg,
Manitoba,
we know what I mean.
I would never have put myself in that place to look bad,
but here he is and here it is and I'm cheering for him as a store,
as a human being in a weird situation that has been put himself into a deep dark
hard spot and saying my way out of this is to try really hard and really go in
and,
and the chance all of that I would want for him if I knew them and he was my
friend is to fight your way through some adverse situations to be able to be in
it and find when it's hard you discover,
yeah I can handle it when it's hard,
I can,
I can get up when I've been dropped or I can fight through not being able to
breathe.
If he loses and does that,
it will have been worth it for him.
No matter how much ridicule he'll take,
What was really weird watching him walk to the cage was that he was approaching
and liga pro wrestling fight cause he had done so many of these pro wrestling
matches that he was walking to the cage with like pro wrestling,
mannerisms,
everything.
And I all,
I was watching this and I,
you know,
I did like an internal head shake.
Like fuck yeah,
like this.
You can't,
it was a terrible idea.
Like whoever his side said that he could fight Micky Gall,
you're out of your fucking mind.
Watch that kid fight once a kid is very good on the ground,
very good.
Big and strong young standups.
Not bad either.
You know,
and he's tough as shit and he's smart,
he's clever and he's mean.
He's mean fucker.
And that is at that stage he was maybe one to know,
I think,
uh,
maybe too,
but it's still the lowest level that there is in the entire elite world of
fighting.
Not that it didn't matter the way.
One,
like you saw it,
you saw the way it took that guy's back and the way sinks hooks in when he was
on top and just delivering that type.
Yeah,
that's,
and you're 100% right.
What if somebody is watching that?
That is the reality of thinking I won't really war I,
I'll put myself in a situation that I can't win,
but I've got guts and heart and I believe I'm going to do it.
You get the metaphorical version of that punch in the face.
If you go through life like that,
yes you do and you know what?
You shouldn't do it in fighting because you don't want those punches in the face
if you can't avoid them.
Like if,
if you're in a situation where you're,
you want to prove your toughness and you want to be battled against someone
who's of your skill level and try to figure your way through the maze of this
contest,
that makes sense.
What doesn't make sense is getting punched in the face unnecessarily.
And when you fight,
in my opinion,
when I looked at that fight,
I was like,
Mickey galls going to smash him.
This is just how it's going to go.
There's very few fights where I can tell you this is absolutely gonna happen.
Like,
here's a perfect example.
Ropy Hofeld dose on Joe's,
uh,
against,
Colby Covington.
I don't know what the fuck's happened.
No idea how to,
no,
no.
We're going to get in there.
They're gonna throw it down.
Let's see.
Micky gall versus,
you know,
um,
I forgot to cm punk.
What's his real name?
Phil Jackson.
No apartment.
Whatever.
Yeah.
Cm punk.
What is it?
Jamie Brooks.
Brooks.
Phil Brooks.
Sorry,
Phil.
Um,
I was like,
well,
he's,
this is a terrible idea because he's just going to get,
you can only get punched in the face so many times in your life.
Yeah.
And you have a number,
whatever the number is,
everybody's different.
Mark Hunt's number seems to be extraordinarily high.
Yeah.
You know,
there's some people that could just take it and this is true,
but you know,
you don't want it when you can't avoid it.
And he could,
he's not gonna avoid it in that fight and I'm just going to get smashed and less
make,
he caught a crazy armbar early in the fight and that was what he gave him.
That's,
yeah.
Other than that he's getting his face smashed in and you should not do that if
you don't have to.
But that,
I remember when we spoke about it,
it's unconscious incompetence and that if you don't know what you don't know,
like it's a really fucking weird place to be.
And we go through life that way a lot of times
in a lot of different contacts until you find out,
you know,
conscious incompetence where like,
oh fuck,
I don't know anything about this.
And he wasn't even at that point.
Now he's at that point and he has a lower level thing.
So,
and you know,
he didn't,
it was a mistake to start down this road.
But you're down at now.
You're on it now.
So,
you know,
it seems to me that,
I mean,
he's taken,
what,
two years since that fight.
Yeah.
It's been about two years getting there and we've subsequently got to see Micky
Gall and some contests against some really tough guys age.
Yeah.
Beat some good guys.
And we got to see like,
okay,
this kid is fucking for real,
which is what we suspected all along.
But we don't know anything about Phil.
We haven't seen him spar,
we haven't seen retrained.
But from what I saw when I first saw him training the,
the first,
you know,
when I first saw him sparring and moving around,
it's like,
God damn,
there's a lot of work to be done.
Like,
you know,
like first steps of Everest work to be done.
It's like,
this is,
um,
we're not talking about a guy who has like a deep background in martial arts,
like a Brock Lesnar wrestling is absolutely a martial art.
He was a legit top of the food chain amateur wrestler.
He was a fucking
monster and a physical monster.
I mean,
yeah,
that and a psychological monster,
like fighting his skills for sure.
But it's your body and it's your mind.
And when you are a heavy competitor,
when you focus,
when you're able to focus in the deepest,
most fearful conditions,
you know,
uh,
Brock Lesnar did that,
you know,
and uh,
physically when you're aware,
like you said,
we are aware of where your body is in space and how to control it.
That can take a lifetime.
And so it's a weird one,
but
something you also develop as a child,
as a young kid.
Like when you're in your developmental years,
1314,
15,
you're body's growing and it's growing into whipping kicks and punches and
shooting takedowns and landing chokes.
Your body develops that way.
When you're a full grown man in your thirties and then you're starting to throw
roundhouse kicks in front kicks and you're,
your body's all goofy and shit and it doesn't,
doesn't want to listen.
Right?
It's not pliable.
It's not elastic.
It says that you're a different animal.
You can still learn anything.
You at 50 years old,
you can take up anything in the world.
You'd take up anything and you should,
yeah,
you should be shitting,
you know,
go in the NFL with it.
Or if you start playing piano when you're 50 you should learn to play piano and
show all your friends that you know the song or,
but you can't go like,
you know,
be in a concert piano scenario where you're going to fail and,
and doing it and saying,
you know,
I believe doesn't make a difference when you can't physically or mentally or
psychologically do these things.
But I still think learning and growing and chasing things and self improvement
is the root of who we are.
I agree.
Yeah.
I think it is too.
But you can't be a 34 year old man has never boxed a day your life and have a
goal
to in 12 months fight Loma Chanko no,
no.
It's never going to happen.
And if it does happen,
it's going to be a disaster.
And that there are giant exceptions like one in a million of things where people
do things,
but there's always some other explanation.
And often it is as a youth,
they created the neural pathways and the physicality and the connection to their
body.
You know,
I was,
uh,
I did gymnastics when I was a kid and I loved it.
It's great base.
Yeah,
I loved it.
And,
and,
and you know,
it helps you physically understand where your body is.
And so later on in life,
I was always at least okay at sports because I understood how to move my body in
space and I understood where my hand was compared to my foot and how I balanced
and,
and to learn that as a child,
somebody who was a master of something as a kid who at 30 picks up another thing
and has some really advanced learning abilities.
There are exceptions that we see rare exceptions,
but,
but you're right,
I mean reality still reality.
I wonder too,
if those exceptions are genetic,
I wonder if like maybe perhaps someone in their family was a great athlete and
it's transferred through their genes,
which I am as I get older,
a firm believer in,
um,
I just don't think we know enough about what transfers through genes.
But there's some freaky shit I see in my kids in particular where I go,
okay,
that is my fucking personality.
That's the something and I'm not teaching her to do this.
This is something that's in her like this,
the repetitive g like exercise,
like doing things over and over again,
obsessively like there's,
there's some weird shit that like,
I'm like,
I wonder if that's a neural pathway that's passed down through the DNA.
I mean it just seems like there could be a person who's never engaged in
athletics,
but maybe their grandfather was like a world champion boxer and then one day
they put on the gloves and then they just sorta like start moving around and the
coach was like,
Hey,
what the fuck's going on here?
Where'd you learn how to throw a jab like that?
I'm forgetting.
Francis and Ghana's coach's name,
I forget his name is Fernando Lopez.
Yes.
He's a wonderful guy.
A smart guy.
Really.
He's been around like the best of the best through Europe,
so and Cameroon to France and these areas.
And he's seen the best of the best that that genetic crop of humans has to
offer.
And then Francis and got it walks into his gym and you talk to Y'all next time
you see for an end to ask them about this cause you see his eyes light up like
that thing where this like a color in the eye and he's like,
you know,
I just knew,
like he said,
I watched him do things in his awareness of his body and how he could physically
express himself.
He said he had just never seen anything like it and this is,
you know,
week one in the gym,
he said first sparring session.
He didn't really know how to fight yet,
but he said he saw him adapting and learning within the round against somebody
who knew how to fight and you see it in his eyes.
He,
he literally found fucking Unicorn
just strolled in off the street and came in.
And then he was like,
man,
if he's had some work ethic,
if he is like,
you know,
if he's passionate about this,
if he can commit and learn and all that,
it goes physically,
genetically speaking,
this human being,
the length of his bones,
the,
the speed of his neurology,
all of these things he said you just knew and you see it in his face.
You're like,
oh fuck.
That must have been wild.
Like it must have been wild to,
to experience that when you have a lifetime of seeing.
Yeah.
It's like that scene in the color of money.
I don't know if you ever saw the movie of course with Paul Move Paul Newman and
Tom Cruise when a Paul Newman,
here's Tom Cruise,
break the balls for the first time.
It turns a rose.
What the fuck is going on over here?
And he looks over and he sees his kid.
There's,
there's certain people that just have this crazy talent and when someone has
been around for a long time as a coach and had a bunch of untalented or
reasonably talented are very talented people.
This,
this big stew of humans coming to their gym and you see that one unicorn that
steps in and he's also case where his father,
I mean he doesn't have a backer,
he didn't have a background in martial arts before he started training,
but his father was a great street fighter and it's entirely possible that
something was carried on through him or
something was present in both.
That allowed them both to be capable of doing that rather than the learn to
pass.
Cause we don't know how that passes genetically from,
from behavior.
We know that genetically we may behave similar to our parents,
our kids,
right.
When we don't know if that came from that.
But uh,
I just,
I'm a hoe this weirdly uncomfortable thinking about genetics because I don't
like the idea that we're limited by them.
And I know that we're not on some level,
but we are,
but,
but then I'm not going to play basketball.
He has since Lebron James.
But if we identified no,
no,
we're not.
No.
Where we do,
it's not going to go.
Whoa.
Okay.
No,
there's some,
there's definitely some truths.
I mean,
I'm five foot six on a tall day.
Like that is a genetic limitation that is undeniable.
Right.
Um,
but if we're looking at things and we decide that our genes,
have you seen the movie Gattica they ever seen them?
We've been,
I did see that movie a long time ago.
That's why my favorite movies ever.
Matt,
Ethan Hawke.
Train hoc.
Yeah.
I always think of him as Uma Thurman.
Yeah,
she's in it.
I know,
but I think of him cause he used to be married to her.
I'm like,
oh,
that's Uma Thurman Thurman.
But you know what I mean?
Yeah.
In that movie,
his brother is genetically superior to him,
but he beats his brother in the swimming contests all the time.
And at the end his brother is like,
how are you doing this?
And he said,
I never saved anything for the swim back.
I was just going to swim to the other side.
And his brothers,
like there is no fucking other side.
But it was a [inaudible].
I know it's a movie,
but it was a mindset.
Right.
And the truth is that's like talent.
Okay.
So you're talented at certain things and Jamie's talents a certain things.
Francis and Ghana.
Talented talent multiplied by effort equals skill.
Yeah.
Then skill multiplied by effort equals accomplishment.
So effort counts twice,
right?
Yeah,
for counts fucking twice.
But then you get effort with a talented guy with freak genetics,
like a Lebron James or a Michael Jordan or Brock Lesnar and then you get some
crazy
results.
Yes.
Oh,
big time.
And the guy who doesn't have the,
the talent but had effort twice,
effort was applied twice.
We'll go as far as the man or woman will go as far as they possibly could to
actualize their true potential by committing themselves to,
to effort and not going,
well,
I can't do it.
So forget it.
By applying effort over and over and over again.
And then once you've developed talent,
more effort to take that talent and do something that twice used effort,
we'll get you as far as you possibly can.
If you say,
well,
I'm not gifted,
I'm not talented,
so I won't put in any effort.
You have no idea how far you can go.
So I absolutely cannot beat Francis in Ghana,
but by not thinking that I'm too limited by my jeans and continuing to apply
effort,
regardless of my jeans,
I can get to the best possible place I can as an individual.
Do you know what I mean?
So I think that that on some,
you don't want to go down some road that you cannot be accomplished,
but you also don't want to not go down roads because you're not genetically
predisposed to them.
I think African get you somewhere.
It definitely can get you somewhere.
But I think what we're talking about here is what I love about life is that it's
messy.
Yeah.
That there's not,
it's not one plus one is two,
isn't it?
There's not as Zeros and ones.
It's just,
there's a bunch of factors.
Does a lot of shit going on,
man.
And that's why when something magical takes place,
when you get,
uh,
you know,
George Saint Pierre,
or when you,
you get a mighty mouse,
when you get someone who's like,
Whoa,
look at that,
like this,
there's so many factors that lead you to be,
uh,
Gennady.
Golovkin yeah.
There's so many different things have to fall into place.
Or here's a guy,
like,
how about Michael Bisping?
Michael Bisping is just one of the toughest motherfuckers ever example.
Yeah.
But you found the perfect,
yeah.
Michael Bisbing is one of the toughest motherfuckers ever.
He's not extraordinarily talented in any one form of MMA.
He's not like the fastest guy.
He's not the strongest guy.
He doesn't have this great background in Brazilian Jujitsu where he's just a
worldclass strangler.
And if he gets your back,
you're fucked.
There's none of those things.
He's just tough as fuck.
And he's one of the most mentally strong guys.
Like even Tim Kennedy who was here the other day,
Tim Kenny,
he's like,
God,
I hate to give him a compliment.
Police.
So fucking tough can't,
you can't deny them.
You
can't.
So,
and,
and that goes right back to this,
and I think this is at the root of questions about life because Michael Bisbing
genetically tough.
Is he genetically mentally tough or did he work really hard and just push
himself through things?
And that one day when it got really fucking tough,
he didn't give up,
which taught him that he shouldn't give up,
which taught him to go even further,
which made him push himself or was it in all likelihood it's both.
But Michael Bisping free of that effort to continue to because um,
oh,
what's his name?
Think of the mentally toughest guy that,
um,
I'm just,
I have a thing with names sometimes,
even names I know I'll describe.
Guy's got a chain and he's howling and he's does it power slam.
But I can't think of ramping up.
I can't think of rampage,
but,
uh,
big elbows.
You've had him probably on the podcast,
a tough hairy chest.
Um,
uh,
who am I thinking?
I'm hundred and 70 pounds fought Damien Maia,
Matt,
Matt Brown.
Oh yeah.
But that's an example.
I can literally say,
she could literally say all these things,
but the name will escape me.
It's a strange thing happens to me.
I worked with John Early in the morning,
right?
I worked with John Ramm Dean for you.
This is one of my best friends.
And he would literally just see it in my eyes,
just like I won't have the name and I'll throw out one or two of those factoids.
And he always had it.
It'd be like Matt Brown.
So that's why having good friends with his great,
you'll know your pants.
Yeah.
But we've talking to Matt Brown and on the phone,
I,
uh,
doing an interview with them.
I said,
you're one of the mentally toughest guys there is.
And he said,
I don't think I am.
He said,
if I think I'm mentally tough for one moment,
I will not do all of the things necessary to walk in mentally tough.
He said,
he's like,
Ma,
I am not mentally tough.
The mental toughness is a result of all of the hard work and preparation that I
have done to be able to do it in that moment.
And you heard it in his voice.
He had no doubt that this was so,
and I think he's right.
I think he's right.
I think he's right too.
But he's also mentally tough him because he also does those things.
But one of the things that about Matt Brown that separates him is that that guy
empties out in the cage.
He separates himself from the pack because he,
he's so for Roche bus like that guys for Roche's remember when,
when he stepped into the cage we were watching,
I think we're doing a fight companion,
but we're um,
maybe we were wearing it anyway when he stepped into the cage and fought Diego
Sanchez when he,
when he stepped into the octagon and screamed and roared,
it was literally like an animal.
I mean it was,
it was far verocity defined and that's just how we fights man.
That kind of just empties out.
Like whatever the fuck he's guy.
He's not holding anything back,
man.
He,
he goes for it.
And that's why I think when we were talking about fight an art,
to me that's an art of human expression.
Like,
I think that is to be a capable,
I mean,
whether you're um,
you're doing jazz or punk rock,
it's human expression.
Whether are Matt Brown or your some elegant mover.
It's still the same art at its root.
But you remember that elbow he fired on Diego Sanchez and that's fine.
It was there and there.
The,
these moments are there a lot when you're analyzing,
fighting and looking at it from that other perspective,
these fight ending moments are there.
They're,
there are way more often than these guys realize,
but when they spot them like Matt did in that moment,
this is,
I have a free shot from an angle.
Time has slowed down enough that I see it.
I can see the little red arc of where it's going and I'm going to put this,
I'm going to end this fight.
It,
it's,
there's a visceral like,
like uh,
it's period is when people look at you see it,
see?
Yup.
Just like that is fucking art to me.
But watch the lefthand,
the reach and the hold and it's like,
there is no doubt with what's happening here.
There is no doubt.
Diego Sanchez is another curious example because he's also a guy who is
ferocious,
like a ferociously tough guy.
But there's always been something about his movements that makes him come up
short against the best of the best.
And I mean you're talking about a guy who's so fucking mentally tough as well.
Like I always bring his fight against Jake Ellenberger who is a brutal knockout
artists at one 70 and Diego really,
I mean Diego fought at one 45 remember?
And Diego really is a tweener.
He's like a little too small for 55.
I don't know how the fuck he made it to one 45.
He basically starved his body away and probably did some error,
irreversible damage.
But he will was like,
his movements are always just shy of elite.
And I've always wondered what is that like?
It's almost like even if you see that,
go back to that clip again,
but you don't have to.
It's okay.
But there's something about even the way he steps,
yeah,
he's not stepping the way,
uh,
Tj Dillashaw steps.
You know what I'm saying?
He's,
I see it as his sort of intention.
It's his over into,
Oh God,
that is so nasty,
nasty and so perfect.
But I see he wants it badly.
Like he is,
he's over engaged.
I think it's psychological as much as anything I would say in Albuquerque.
Look at that.
The placement of the left hand there,
there's just no doubt where this is going.
And it is the moment that Matt Brown created,
like he created that moment.
Um,
see hair chest to her charts.
It's funny.
That's one of my reminder cues,
right?
Uh,
but,
uh,
I think so.
I watched Diego train in Albuquerque and I love the guy.
Um,
I was there doing interviewing Cobb,
who is my favorite artists probably to watch for many reasons.
I'm not really sure exactly why people can't tell you why their favorite band is
their favorite band.
But I can all,
there are many things I can describe it,
but I was there to interview for Monster Zim Itsm a,
a website in South Korea that when I became a freelancer,
they were like,
we'd like to give you some work.
I'm like,
well that'd be amazing.
We'd like you to go.
He just fought do whole choice.
We'd like you to go interview Mr Cub Swanson.
I'm like,
this is bad ass.
It's like my favorite fighter.
I'm going to send me to Albuquerque.
And then I hung out in the gym and analyze them and watched and made notes about
what I could and Diego try and super intense and he like does everything super
intense and and as much as he loves yoga and the different types of Yoga and
meditation has allowed him to do it differently,
that hyper intensity,
I think that doesn't allow the sort of soft relaxation that's necessary to
really do what you're describing.
You know?
I know what you're saying.
Like the one of the things that people don't understand about striking hard and
like having real power is that you're not fully tense through the entire
movement.
There's a lot of parts of striking where the momentum starts and you're almost
like completely loose,
like up until instance before the point of contact and then it's playing.
There's this,
there's this weird thing that real knockout artists have that you don't see in
these fucking tense windmill guys.
Windmill guys are too tight.
Totally.
But a guy like Ray Robinson will throw up.
Like there's a,
there was a gene Fullmer ray Robinson Kao clip from the other night.
Uh,
I was,
I was watching online.
I must have washed it like 13 times in a row.
But you watch them Landis,
I think it was a left hook,
but you watched the punch land like cheeses,
like the snap that that guy had.
But that snap is not,
it's not,
it's not fully tense.
Here it is right here.
Like look how nice and soft ts.
Yeah.
Soft.
Look at that lead.
That left Hook right there.
That one's,
softens them up,
ties him up.
But everything is like the way it's flowing.
That,
yeah,
he's swimming.
Yeah.
I mean it's just,
he was a amazing boxer,
dude.
And you're talking about a guy who had like a hundred and something fights,
right?
It's,
he's almost gentle.
I like,
he's soft is the right word.
There's a suppleness.
There's a,
there's a calmness,
there's a relaxation and mentally too,
like you know that idea of there's a storm going on and in the middle of their,
this calm area,
that gentleness,
that,
that calmness has to be in your mind to allow you to do this.
And that's where Diego is.
Look at that.
Come on man.
Just look at this,
that,
that's fucking incredible.
And I left,
took right here.
Here it is.
Yeah.
I mean,
and even just to create that moment and to see that moment and to set it up and
lay traps and see when the guys moving his hands down,
see when he's coming forward.
See is patterns and 10 they can do those things.
Yup.
Yup,
But it's that kind of power in that left hook that does not come from,
that's just a,
that's just this little twist that he does.
Like come on.
But here
it is right here in slow Mo Bang.
And it's just hip and there's like,
so I did,
I'm sure you saw it or I think you saw it.
I did a little breakdown of your kicks.
I did see that.
And it's just,
that's what I was zooming in on was this double pulse and that's real.
That's daddy is the neurology of high athletic performance.
Um,
so I have these friends that I've developed that I've gathered over the years
and I love what I do,
man.
Like I'm happy every single day.
And a big part of it is I've met these people that I have these conversations
with and sometimes they're very long and deep and,
and they've some,
I have friends that are a phd psychologist and this one guy doctor Stu McGill.
Do you know who he is?
His name?
Yeah.
You've probably heard that name.
I'm sure somebody has mentioned it because you're around different athletic
types of all types.
He is the world's foremost expert in the spinal cord,
in neurology of athletic performance,
spinal cord,
the spinal cord and how and your neurology and your nerves and how your nervous
system and George St Pierre has worked with him a lot.
He,
if you ask him about him this week,
he would talk about them extensively.
So doctor Stu and I became friends and it's a big compliment because he sought
me out based on seeing my work and saying that guy knows some things I want to
talk to him,
which was a plaque and deep compliment to me.
And now we became friends and we chat all the time and one of the things we
constantly talk about is the double pulse and neurology and people talk about a
fast twitch fiber.
It's not a fiber as that's just terms we've started to hear.
It's a fast twitch and neurology.
It's,
it's a base,
a fast ball hitters have it.
You know what I mean?
That neurology where you you there's a pulse of tension and then a complete
relaxation until the pulse of tension.
Again,
the Bruce Lee's one inch punch was the simple example of them.
But that is how that is the neurology of high athletic performance and that's
what I zoomed in I when I was looking at your kick cause you can see it quite
clearly.
There's the moment,
there's the relaxing,
those are,
and it ends up being more of a whip.
And stew,
Doctor Stu has all these incredible analogies because he's examined this in so
many different angles and layers,
which is the beauty of analyzing anything for years.
And he'll use terms like you can't shoot a,
a cannon out of a canoe and you think about that and you're like,
of course we can use all walk,
but if it's tense and then shoots or you can't push a rope,
right?
You push a rope,
And so,
but you can whip a rope through tension,
relaxation and tension again.
And that neurology is the neurology of high performance.
And George,
you talked to George about neurology.
He'll go deep down some shit to George Saint Pierre because he studied this to
understand himself and what he was doing at a high level with doctors too.
Um,
but it is a fascinating thing because when you think,
we often will say,
you know,
fighting is 90% mental sipping.
This cop is 100% mental.
You know,
my brain told my body to reach out and do it.
My brain made this choice.
I activated everything.
Use,
it's all your brain,
everything.
And once you get to a high level of performance,
you know how to punch and kick and you train like crazy and you make the things
happen by themselves almost by training so much,
they take so little attention in decision making.
It becomes about maximizing your nervous system,
how your nervous system.
And I think that's true of almost anything.
And that's not the steer right there.
Yeah.
That Susie training with the charge and doctors too.
I couldn't see his face looks like a bar graph and to be honest,
yeah.
But uh,
that is got,
I'm whipping the ball around.
Yeah.
I'm not sure exactly what he's doing or why they're dumbbell presses,
but I'll put you in touch with them often.
So it's like a,
it looks like he's got some heavy weight at the end of a rope.
Yeah.
And I guess engaging the core through the use of,
you know,
probably asking him to only engage certain things to counter balance the
movement
prize,
to see George waring,
your typical a running shoe when he's training with the,
the thick heel.
And you know,
I'm still surprised to this day when I see,
uh,
we're going to talk about neurology and activating muscles and tissues.
Like there's so many athletes is still train with those big cushy bottomed
running shoes.
I mean,
I think that is crazy victim.
It's weird.
Yeah,
it's weird.
I mean,
you should be doing that kind of shit barefoot,
especially a fighter.
You fight barefoot.
You should be wearing nothing on your feet.
The only thing connecting you to a stable surfaces your foot.
Yeah,
I agree 100%.
Um,
sometimes when we're trying to make sense of these things,
we go to multiple different sort of perspectives of it.
So I'll take what I learned from Doctor Stu and,
uh,
he's just my friend now as well.
So I like hanging out and chatting with him about like way out there,
aspects of these things.
But you talked to Irwin [inaudible] as well,
who has a different sphere of connecting to this kind of thing and Irwin starts
with the foot and you've had our one on the and he starts with the foot and
everything else.
It makes sense,
right?
I got to throw a punch and the important part is going to be my foot through the
leg,
through the hip,
through the core,
and,
and relaxed until the moment that it hits.
But it all starts on
nick.
Nick's,
excuse me.
When I asked Nick Curse on about training athletes,
like what's the,
the thing that he thinks fighter should work on the most?
He's like foot strength.
What?
I was like,
wow.
And I thought about it.
I'm like,
whoa.
Of course.
Right.
That's how you push off.
That's how you move.
I'll give,
your feet are weak and they get tired.
He can't move well,
which I've experienced.
I'm sure you've experienced,
um,
when your feet are weak and tired,
like if you,
if you don't run and then you try to run one of the first things you get tired
of your feet.
Yeah.
The very worst injury I've ever had in my life by far was plantar fasciitis of
both feet.
Oh my last fight.
And I was through training and everything.
And then I had my fight in Montreal and the whole strategy was put,
getting to a place where I could be safe and use better knowledge of the
situation to fatigue the other guy.
So the whole,
a lot of the seven or eight minutes of the fight took place with me,
pressuring him against the fence,
just driving off both feet,
pressuring against the fence to try to land things are make,
create lines for different weapons.
And it's only eight minutes,
but eight minutes of intense drive from my feet.
And then we went on vacation the very next day and that night we grabbed
Margarita's and we walked around the resort and in my feet were destroyed for
acutely,
for three or four days.
Like I couldn't walk.
And the inflammation was so unbelievably bad.
It was like bricks.
And,
uh,
even for months after it was visualized him tried to ice ice or I would get in
immediately into the cold pool and spend the day in the cold pool drinking
Tequila and hopes that it would help.
And it's kind of,
yeah,
foot pain is,
that's one of the things that are hurt.
Dominick Cruz in his comeback fight when he fought Tj Dillashaw you notice he
was like kind of limping a little.
We were attributing it to the leg kicks.
He said that's not the case.
He said what was going on was he had plantar fasciitis because you know he had
multiple injuries that he was re re recovering from during that training camp.
And when he got knee surgery and he came back from that and he tore his groin,
he tried to like really ramp up as training,
who's doing a lot of sprinting and a lot of different things with his feet.
You know,
cause obviously he's very footwork intensive with his fighting and he fucked his
feet up.
Man.
His feet just weren't and conditioned to do the kind of stuff that he used to be
able to do.
And the first thing he got was plantar fasciitis shop had it too.
He told me it was.
That's one of the worst things he's ever had.
Think of this for the big picture meaning of this far Dominic.
So you got somebody else and they're going about fighting and their their career
as a martial artist,
a competitive fighter one way and Dominic goes about it a different way and
through Dominic's choices,
moving training,
footwork,
he avoids a lot of the damage that these guys will take,
but you can't avoid,
something's going to go right.
So instead of taking,
getting kicked a lot and punched in the head and taking all those things,
the training necessary to make that not happen fucks up something else.
Like you can't get away from it.
You're going to work yourself until your body gives up.
Even dom brilliantly finding a way to work outside of taking the damage that
they take still could not get away from damaging his body.
Tj Dillashaw versus Cody Garbrandt.
The rematch is one of the most intriguing fights of the year for me.
I'm really,
really curious about that fight because I know those guys were tightly matched
in the gym and I know that Cody correct him with a big right hand before TJ put
him away.
And so,
and it was,
yeah,
he was stunned and he rocked.
And I believe when Cody cracked and it was towards the end of the round,
he was,
yeah.
And so he had an opportunity to recover.
I mean,
who knows if he had caught that right hand the first minute of the round what
had gone on.
But when Tj recovered from that and then lend that head kick and then you know,
knocked him out and put him away,
you,
you got to see like,
oh,
what a high level high stakes game these two guys are playing.
And you know,
Tj has through bang,
Ludwig has really radically improved his movement,
his footwork,
his angles,
his approach.
He's so versatile with his ability to switch stances,
his ability,
I mean,
he's constantly cutting angles and striking as he switching stances.
And there's so much information coming at you.
If you're fighting him,
your,
your brain's overloaded.
If you're not used to that and even the guys who used to train with them,
I believe in Alpha male are not used to what he's doing now.
I agree because it's a,
it's at a,
at a far higher level that said,
Cody still has a fucking missile in his right hand.
It's so goddamn fast.
His hand speed is so fast and his,
his fluidity and efficiency in his boxing is so good.
It's just a very,
very interesting fight for me.
That's about as good as it gets right now,
like from the raw materials of those guys and the skills that they have.
But I am definitely with you as far as that,
my deep curiosity of the choices of the coaches and because,
and you talk to some of them different ones,
you know,
I've got a few key friends that I talk to on a very regular basis and so what it
will take,
what we would decide to do to train to make our guy the best in the world or try
to be the best in the world in 10 months.
If we take a different strategy and we start to build them to be the best in the
world in three years,
it's a different game.
And that's what Dwayne,
Dwayne is sad.
We will and it's,
it's fucking hard work for Dwayne to like,
that's the thing that people won't necessarily appreciate.
They'd be like,
oh,
he's a brilliant coach.
That's nonstop,
constant searching and examining and trial and error and reinterpreting his
language of understanding where the,
where the chaos is and understanding,
you know,
can we make this guy believes something's happening or are we too deep in it
that he doesn't think that and it fails.
Like what levels of misdirection or too deep,
how good is he?
And when I talked to them leading up to that one,
it was like,
you know,
the conversation was about making Cody believe in,
anticipate something wrong.
And that's the root of all of all combat,
right?
Like you make me think this is coming and I do this and he took me in the body.
And the layers,
the multiple layers,
like you just said,
overloading the ability to,
you're trying to catalog what's coming and how you chunk that,
uh,
we don't necessarily understand.
So your brain be going,
okay,
this is all the stuff from the left,
which happens when this happened or the,
the,
the legs are doing this or you're running algorithms in your brain and we don't
know.
I don't know what yours is.
I don't know how you categorize my threats.
I don't know whether you categorize anything from my right hand or anything in
combination or if you're watching the patterns of my shoulders,
I have no idea.
So Dwayne and anybody else playing with this concept is trying to figure out how
you'll read this and use that against you.
And to me,
that's the,
the layer of complete mind blowing nature that like,
what did you say?
Chess with dire consequences or problem.
Solvable problems.
Fucking hard.
Those problems are now how many there are.
That's the game.
And,
and it can be done at this level because their skills are so good.
They're minds are so good.
They're physically so good,
they're capable,
they're fearless,
they're confident,
they have all of those raw materials and now we're playing a game that most of
us cannot comprehend and they've also sparred countless hours to those each
other and they've told each other lies for long periods of time.
Lies on lies.
I one time went with a,
I worked for a company called the score fighting series.
It was really a brilliant show.
Like it was kind of Canada's Bella tour,
like it was on the same network and they aired Bella tour and it was very,
very good developmental league stuff.
And that company brought in Forrest Griffin and then a bunch of poker players
and they were on a train together and and contest winners on the thing.
Got To ride on this train with Forrest Griffin and a bunch of poker pup but high
level pro poker players.
And I was there and that was the first time I met Forrest.
And this is a killer,
smart dude.
But you watch these poker players who are all riding together and they all know
each other and they are just telling each other lies all the time,
trying to tell stories about things that represent the fact that they are,
you know,
conservative when really they're risk takers are trying to tell each other
things that make them think they're crazy.
But really they're calculating like they are telling each other lies ongoing and
they're gambling with each other and shit.
It's a completely dejected,
generative,
but that's the kind of thing that's happening on some level with these,
the high level fighters to making them think certain things about what they will
do or believe they'll do almost everything they say.
Um,
we should,
the fans and the audience we should assume is a game chip is like a something to
make.
The other one believes something that might in that moment,
let me land that kick.
If he thinks that I'm,
you know,
whatever,
right.
It's manipulative stuff and at that level that is just so unbelievably
fascinating.
It really is.
In the stakes are so high and you know,
the kick lands your hero,
the kick misses and you get caught with a left hook,
you're a loser.
You know,
there's just so much at stake with every single choice you make and all,
all those choices have to be almost subconscious or semi-conscious because
you've got to be in the Zen state,
you gotta be flowing.
So everything has to be prepared.
You have to have,
you know,
while you're in there,
you have
to have no regrets.
You have to be able to just flow and you have to be able to capitalize on any
movement,
any,
any opening.
You say you got to pounce and they have to be in condition to execute all these
things.
So you have to have had the physical discipline and the mental fortitude to push
yourself through training to a level that you probably didn't think you could
get to.
And,
and I want to pounce with the opening,
but what if it's a lie?
Right?
Right.
Like,
what if Matt Brown slot line on that thing was actually,
that one would be hard to be alive,
but there are other ones where it feels like that one little opening but instead
Tj is going to catch you or Cody's lined you up to draw you into something.
So God damn fast to his hand speed is so ridiculous.
He fasts,
I go back to the Tom saw modified and Almeda has really never been the same
again.
I'll made it going into that fight was undefeated,
was thought to be the dark horse of the division like w look or future world
champion.
And Cody lit him up like a Christmas tree.
And the way he did it was so definitive that you like Jesus.
Like there could be no doubt this guy has real world championship potential.
You know?
And I think that the Duane Ludwig factor is so fucking huge or really,
really do.
And I,
I,
I've seen Dwayne's work in like Dwayne,
unlike a lot of guys has notebooks like binders full of ideas and his system is
a,
it's a very declared system.
It's not like loosely based work.
We always work off the jab.
We've got good footwork,
none.
There's none of that.
No.
Like there's a system to his,
like he has a belt system to his style and his style is based on for people
don't know.
Dwayne was a worldclass kickboxer worldclass Muay Thai fight.
I mean fought Ramon Dekkers,
I mean fought some of the best of the best,
had some amazing fights in both MMA and in kickboxing.
And he was a really talented guy and then transitioned on to being a coach.
And the obsession that he has towards coaching is really at a higher level than
even his obsession towards fighting.
And he talks about that,
that his passion is teaching people.
He loves it.
He loves being able to mold students and he's found the perfect muse or the
perfect willing participant in Tj and teaching him.
I have a very unique friendship and very unique student mentorship sort of
relationship.
It's really,
really interesting to watch the two of them together.
Wild.
Now the the Super Jam with 20 guys and then you've got,
uh,
and Dwayne has tons of athletes too,
but,
but a commitment and connection to Tj.
Then you've got Matt Hume and Demetrius,
like you've got a few of these guys who are just like,
we,
you,
we will funnel all of my experience through everything through this super
athlete.
But like you talk about those books,
the only way that you get to a point of this level of mastery that we're talking
about is that you must go down some fucking road for six months that amounts to
nothing so that you learned that road isn't the road and the only way and you
can't give up too worldly.
And what if by going down at long enough,
some different concept about how you switch your feet in a certain moment.
You think maybe that ain't it.
But you have discovered that by pushing through some of these concepts long
enough,
you find it so you stick with it long enough and it turns out no.
Dwayne and or anybody else reaching that level of mastery has gone down some
rabbit hole for months or years and discovered the only value they got out of it
was,
well no,
there's lots of value that wasn't the rabbit hole.
And the,
the process of searching this rabbit hole has made me better at searching rabbit
holes.
So those two values,
some of the stacks of his books are things that didn't work and he will probably
appreciate those just as much as any of the ones that did.
It was also,
Tj is approach is really interesting to me because Tj is obsessed with
improvement and knowledge and he keeps talking about his fight Iq and you know,
him and Dwayne,
I've been around them,
I've trained with them,
I've worked out with him,
I watched him coach Tj and I mean they're,
they're constantly working on the minutia.
They're constantly working on finite details and improving every single aspect
and tightening things up.
And it's really interesting.
Tj is a fucking open book man.
I mean,
he's,
uh,
he,
you can talk to that guy about anything and he's considering it.
He's thinking and he's like,
oh,
okay,
I see what you're doing.
Like he's,
he's a guy who's always trying to take in information,
you know,
that's,
so these are the things when we do watch this kind of thing,
whether it is martial arts or even your jazz or football or whatever,
there are these lessons that are there,
like,
we should do that.
My corresponds to go through life doing that.
We're not supposed to look at Tj Dillashaw and go,
wow,
isn't that crazy,
that guy,
if we do that,
our lives will get better.
Right?
I got two.
So I get to work for Tsn in Canada,
which is like ESPN at in the states and we,
I'm myself and Aaron broadens that are like the two person division.
It talks about about a UFC and fighting.
And uh,
we,
uh,
they went and when George was fighting Michael,
they went and said,
you know,
could you approach your friends with George and his people?
Could you approach them about doing a half hour long documentary on him about
his comeback and training and stuff?
And I did.
And at first George was open to it and is Rudolph has manager.
I was like,
Oh God,
I hear the word documentary and I know what that means.
It's going to be months and is going to be cameras and it's going to be a
distraction.
I said,
I'll just travel with George and I have the best producer,
Simon,
the best producer we have and we'll just travel with them and they said yes and
so I got to travel with George for a month,
six weeks off and on New York,
La,
Montreal life eating ice cream train with Freddie Roach.
Yeah.
When is this going to come out?
It did come up before,
so mostly in Canada,
but I'm going to send a message.
I'm going to send a message immediately after we get off here to Simon and the
rest of them and say,
where is that right now?
And then I'll,
I'll tweet it out because did learned a lot.
Oh Man.
It changed my life,
like yeah,
because you don't get to be around the greats of the greats and study them and
we're friends.
So I can talk to him like we hang out here,
I got to fucking train karate with his team,
like point karate,
you know,
so it'd be all Robbins training with us today.
What kind of point karate training do they do?
And do they do this to practice like blitzing?
Yep.
And just think of this like an eye.
You were big on point karate like 2012,
2013 and I didn't disagree but I didn't really get there.
It is.
There it is.
Yeah.
It uh oh fuck.
It was so magical to see like,
and I wasn't just like how does he kick?
And I'm like,
how does he,
why does he do the things he does and why?
What's his motivation?
And it really made me a better human being getting to do that.
But um,
so what,
I didn't really connect to a sit.
Sometimes there's something so simple and we don't see it cause we're in,
we're deep in,
up whatever we're in.
But the idea of point karate people right away and say,
well,
they're just touching each other.
It's like a true,
so if I'm training to just touch you,
I'm not trying to hurt you.
Okay.
That seems like that's not valuable,
but you're training to not,
let me even fucking touch you.
Right?
If you can't get touched by me,
how hard,
impossible as it for me to hit you clean.
You know what I mean?
If your movement and your,
your defensive systems and your management of the,
of the distance between our weapons and targets are such that I can't fucking
touch you.
How can I hurt you?
Right.
If I can't even like get touchy with my glove.
Well,
the thing is,
here's what I think about point fighting and what I think was valid about it is
if you're just doing point fighting with a point fighter,
it is extremely frustrated.
I fought in point fighting tournaments when I was competing and we,
there was,
I came from a full contact taekwondo background and we fought in these
tournaments and the object was to knock people unconscious and you would fight,
you know there were three minute rounds and you would fight and you would try to
kick people into another time.
A similar in Canada when it says what we,
there was a lot of people that are trained with that openly dismissed point
fighting.
And the reason why they openly dismissed point fighting was cause they would
stop every time someone would get touched.
And I would be like,
well in the real world or everybody would say in the real world,
you don't just stop when you get touched,
you keep fighting.
And so with our techniques,
a lot of it,
you would hit someone once and they would counter it and then you'd set up the
big shot afterwards.
Like this is part of the thing.
And if the the referee kept stopping you,
then you would never get anything done.
But my thinking once I got into MMA was okay.
Yeah.
But if you can do that and do the other things,
it's like people dismiss taekwondo because there were like,
we'll talk window.
He,
you know,
you get taken to the ground,
you get your legs kicked out.
Absolutely.
But if you have
takedown defense and you know Moitai you can wheel kick someone into another
fucking dimension.
And we saw that with Edson Barboza versus Terry Edom.
We've seen these taekwondo techniques manifest themselves in MMA and you realize
like,
oh,
these are some of the most powerful things you could do to a person inside a
cage.
But when you see the point fighting style,
they'll like the Raymond Daniels or the Michael Venom page.
This ability to blitz if they can do those other things too.
This is another,
another level.
There's something to it.
So as a fighter,
I wasn't willing to dismiss point fighting because I had been lied to already.
I,
when I went and took taekwondo and then started kickboxing,
first American kickboxing above the waist,
first thing I realized is how easy it was for me to get punched in the face.
I was like,
oh,
okay.
Now if I'm trapped in this ring and I can't go anywhere and someone's throwing
punches and I don't understand how to get away from him,
and I'm used to this taekwondo style of having your hands down low,
I'm getting fucked up.
So I've been lied to.
Talk Window is not the best martial art.
None of the Ma.
Yeah,
there's exactly,
I'm nothing.
Exactly.
There is no best much.
There's something absolutely legit about that blitz,
that karate blitz that some of these guys can do.
And I fought some really good guys and those karate style tournaments in and I
got an ass made out of me.
I mean you,
you don't know what to do.
Like and you get kicked and then the referees point and you're like,
you don't have a chance to fire back because they're separating you guys.
And I really absorb those lessons.
And I was like in MMA,
that ability to close the distance because every,
in MMA there's so many guys,
and Connor talked about this,
there's so many guys that have this Moy Thai stance and they're,
they're presenting,
it's very predictable target.
They're standing right in front of each other.
And I think this stance and especially this,
the uh,
change,
the,
the forward stance is one of the reasons why [inaudible] has been caught,
knocked out twice with front kicks because he squares off.
I veto explained this to me in like Shit 1997 when I was training at Carlson
Gracie's,
he was explaining that,
you know,
some kickboxers are going to have a hard time in MMA even though they're really
good kickboxers because the MMA stance,
you really have to square off more.
You can't stand like this.
You can't stand like a boxer.
And a kickboxer is a little more open than a boxer.
But then MMA is a little more open than that.
He's like,
you almost have to be square,
but that's square leaves you open to front kick to the face and then turning
side kicks in.
Side kicks to the body.
Think about what Vito has been dropped with.
Jon Jones dropped him with a side kick to the body.
Soccer.
Robert dropped him with a turning side kick to the body to front kicks with
front kicks to the face.
It's because he presents this square thing.
But to him this is sprawl and throw punches and throw that the like the blitz
that we used on Vandelay Silva and it worked much of his career.
He either with it or lost
with it.
Yeah.
And I'm have respect that thinking.
But those types of doctrines like is literally and in martial arts in day to day
life in anything,
if you think anything is the other thing,
you're totally wrong,
right?
Because if we all agree it's the thing,
then we all acting like it's the thing,
then we all start ignoring other things and those things will work.
So if you have to,
if MMA you have to square up,
all of a sudden some guy,
some Connor comes out with a different thing and you were wrong.
That the guard is the one that is glaring to me right now because,
and I mean I've talked to some of the smartest and the best and they will,
and we do this over and over again.
And we do it in everything.
You know,
you remember when you,
you're,
you cannot cross your feet when you do an arm bar.
Do you remember that?
Or like what the fuck,
what are you talking about?
Head kicks.
Don't work in MMA.
Like you know,
this has been going on forever.
Any absolute decision that this is a fundamental rule is completely,
that's where you're going to get fucked.
And how about the low calf kick?
Yeah,
I mean the look Benson Henderson was in my opinion,
the first guy to bring him and he started doing that back in the day but not to
the effectiveness,
the level of effectiveness that we're seeing now.
That low calf kick his fucking people.
Oh that's really interesting.
And then they'll adapt and then it won't work.
But that adaptation,
we'll put something else available.
Think of the problem with the low calf kick is that you really can't condition
the lower part of your leg the same way you can your thighs.
And I think it's going to keep working,
but then we ask them to not get hit by it.
So we'll make a change to not get hit by and once we do,
that'll force us to do something else that someone will take advantage.
It's amazing how quickly it works.
Like if you see a guy get hit with a brutal leg kick,
like it takes one or two and then they start to feel it.
There's something about the first low calf kick.
You see guys wobbly like that.
That muscle is like really done.
The insertion at the bottom is so small and it's taking so much work like it's
carrying so much.
Yeah,
it's,
and these are when things work beautifully and again,
like I used to take anything we would talk about and I'd bring it back to
fighting.
Now I tend to take anything and fighting and I tried to figure out what it means
in life.
Like I've kind of swell over time of study.
I've started to to do that.
Right.
And this is true of this kick can.
It's true of anything.
It's like the w w it works best when the physiological truth that calf is small
and weak and then works with the systemic issue.
He's got his foot there and the way he's standing as such that you can hit it to
those two things together are making that thing work right now if you can't
change the strength of the calf.
So the only thing we can change is how available that calf kick is if we don't
want to get hit with it.
So we must change that.
And if we do,
we've changed a lot of different things and now something else is available that
Dwayne or Duke or somebody else's already planning how to,
how to take advantage that you've made that adaptation and that that is for me
what is eternally fascinating about martial arts.
But again,
dots,
those are the lessons of life that are there.
If you can't see that the world around you has changed dramatically and you act
as if it's the same,
uh,
you get fucked up,
you will get fucked up.
You know,
I bring this to Paul daily versus John Fitch because,
um,
that fight was extremely frustrating to Paul Daley and frustrating to a lot of
people that were watching it too.
Cause John Fitch was just able to take him down and kind of do what John Fitch
does and hit him on the ground and kind of beat him up and control the position.
And,
and you know,
at the end of the fight Paul's yell and boom,
he seals.
It was so strange,
you know?
And,
but this is a guy that if you just stand with him,
he's going to fuck you up.
Like if you just decide to trade shots with Paul daily on your feet,
he's got a left hand that is a goddamn nuclear missile,
you know,
and he basically,
everybody he hits with that thing goes night night.
It's scary.
Even Lorens Larkin,
who's a seasoned striker,
he got clipped by that left hand.
It's like,
Yo,
the ability to make,
generate and create that amount of impact is elegant.
It's like,
it's like we are human bodies and minds don't do all that many things that are
that unbelievably beautiful and rooted in our history as human beings.
You know what I mean?
This is at the basis of what it was to survive and protect and expand and stuff.
And you see it right there.
When Paul Daley hits somebody like it's unreal.
The opposite of that scenario is,
um,
Johnny Hendricks was fighting Stephen Thompson and Johnny Hendricks wanted,
when Stephen would come in,
he wanted to drill him with hooks and upper cuts and then get to his body and to
take him down and do what,
what,
uh,
John Fitch did.
But Steven's like,
you're not doing that.
And after he kicked him and beat him up at distance and then finish the fight,
Johnny was being interviewed and he's like,
well,
that wasn't my knife.
And Johnny is a classy guy overall over the length of his career,
he sometimes gets heat,
but who cares,
right?
Like the opinion of the people shouldn't matter to Johnny Hendricks.
But Johnny said after he said,
well,
I was kinda hoping he'd come in trade a little more.
It's like,
why the fuck would he do that?
That's not his style.
And that's what you want.
He wants to do what you don't want.
The whole goal is to do something that benefits him in the scenario and does not
benefit you,
which would be exactly what he did,
which is why,
what brings you back to the Paul Daley John Fitch fight like this is the answer
to that style,
the answer to that styles take you down and not ever let you get up and,
and force John Fitches game on you,
which is what makes fighting so interesting.
If John Fitch had just decided to go cowboy and bite down his mouthpiece and
just wing punches that Paul daily until one of them went to sleep,
that would have been a great fight for Paul Dalian.
Great.
China.
Um,
when Nick Diaz and Paul Daley did that,
that was pretty happy and that only happens again.
You're creating a moment and it only happens because nick was motivated by who
he is in that moment.
He wasn't motivated by strategy even necessarily.
He's like,
fuck you.
Like fuck you.
And that however people will look at that.
That is,
again,
it is an expression of the individuality,
the authentic truth of who Nick Diaz is.
That's why that's art.
[inaudible] art and fight.
That's a fight.
This was got a fight,
but that's a little bit of this.
He just,
he just kept the pace.
He's just refusing.
Paul just got too tired too quick.
He was,
he was willing and big shots and look at Nick just oh damn.
Right.
He got clipped.
That's his left hook you're talking about.
Yeah,
this is over.
Okay.
It's all right there.
We're done.
No,
cause nick won't be done.
Well,
I mean,
who knows me.
It was Paul's in better condition.
But this is the end.
The end is nick just battering him.
It's crazy that he beat him his striking contest.
But he did it with Wale.
He was always a great boxer.
But I mean,
and again,
we're this,
we're this a metaphor for life.
Like you got a wall or the greatest victories ever.
The quintessential Nick Diaz fight.
You're get to look at them.
I know,
right?
And there are people who don't like him.
Oh,
I love that guy too,
because that what we're,
what we're searching for,
I think is we are trying to be authentically who we are.
I think that's all we're doing.
That's what Nick Diaz is.
Whatever the fuck you think he is.
He is authentically Nick Diaz and w and the metaphor to me is Paul Daley is a
wall and you can,
you can dig under it or you can go around it or you can trick somebody who gives
you a rope or you can climb it or you can dissemble it.
And Nick's like,
fuck it,
I'm going to go through it.
And there are many ways to choose to live your life and that's how Nick Diaz
lifts his fucking life.
And that's,
that's beautiful.
What sucks is that he hasn't fought in forever.
I mean he hasn't fought since the Anderson Silva fight.
That's crazy.
It's crazy that they suspended him for marijuana when Anderson Silva tested
positive for steroids in that fight and he got a shorter suspension.
The nick,
that's a reflection.
That's a cultural leftover cultural reflection.
That's also the nick refuse to pay the fine cause that's Nick d is being
authentically Nicholas.
You're not getting that money from me.
Oh see ya.
But you can admire that.
Like some,
some people will look at that and go do just pay it.
It'll go this way.
And he said,
no.
Fundamentally who I am,
I cannot do that.
I will get negative consequences in my life,
but I will be authentic to who I am.
But nick is like 36 now I think.
How old is Nick Diaz?
No,
34 he's 34 now.
So yeah.
Well Dude,
his first fight in UFC,
I believe he was 20 you know when he fought Jeremy Jackson like way back in the
day,
he was 18 you
know,
I mean he's been around man,
you know,
he's been a brown so he's still like literally in his physical prime.
I mean,
and this is crazy considering the fact that,
I want to say the Anderson Silva fight was three years ago.
What is the way it feels?
Yeah,
somewhere around there.
I would love to see him back in there again.
You know?
I don't know.
No,
no.
Got To get what you want to do though.
I don't know if he really,
truly,
that's what he wants to do.
He'll,
he'll find a way to do it.
And if he doesn't,
yeah.
You know,
George,
you got George coming in.
I'm,
I asked George,
so my,
at work,
they're like,
hey,
can you see what's up with George and this Nate Diaz?
And I'm like,
well,
ask,
but,
and I'll ask honestly as a friend,
and he knows that I'm also employed by somebody who I have a little
conversation,
but,
but I will never advert sacrifice a friendship or like a longterm relationship
to like find something out on that.
Yeah.
I don't care about,
and I don't care about Twitter beefs and I don't care about the breaking news
and all that.
It's just not interesting.
It's not anything to do with my life.
But I'll go ask George.
So I asked George,
who we are friends,
we talked yesterday and uh,
we will,
he will tell me the truth and then,
and something as simple as all,
you know,
not as fucking bullshit,
maybe not in exactly those terms,
but he would say.
But when I asked him about it,
he's like,
no,
Bro.
Uh,
I haven't signed nothing.
And I looked at that and like,
oh my God,
that's George tried to be deceptive.
Like George would normally go ass be ass man.
That's not happening.
I know I haven't signed anything.
Well I know they've offered him knee,
but that was George,
who's Shitty at being deceptive,
trying to be deceptive like he,
yeah,
so like you said,
they've offered it to,
they've offered it to him and by saying I haven't signed it means he's
considering it.
I think he's considering it,
but I think he's also considering could be number of off and then there's always
the great Irish Leprechaun,
you know mean.
I think those are the two big fights.
The two big fights or could be,
but one 55 or even one 70 yeah.
GSP wants to winner of Conor McGregor versus could be not Nate Diaz insider
drops bombshell and this is May 19th Saturday.
Yeah.
I'm sure he wants that.
But that fight would have to take place first.
And who the fuck knows when Connor or could be,
but fight afterwards if it's Connor,
it might be a decade later.
I mean,
who the fuck knows what that guys going to do?
Now when you give a guy like Conor a hundred million dollars,
you know,
I mean this is what happens.
He's throwing dollars at bus windows and losing his fucking mind and yeah,
that's mad of Jamie,
that UFC inside of a shop,
was it?
Yeah,
it was on his podcast.
I didn't saw that.
Scroll down.
UFC inside Brendan shot those who?
Brendan Schaub as you fucking idiots.
That fucking some obscure insider.
Yeah,
well I'm sure he does want that,
but if they offer him a fat paycheck and they really should,
if they want.
Look,
the UFC is in a weird position.
They,
they bought the company for $4.
I don't know what it's worth,
but I would guess it's probably not really worth $4 billion.
They have a giant monthly nut.
It's fucking huge.
The monthly nut that they have to make caused them to fire a hundred employees.
I mean,
there's a lot going on and there's been some,
you know,
great fights and it's obviously still incredibly popular,
but you want to make those big paper view bucks.
You need the big name stars.
GSP was always a big name.
Star became even bigger when he came back and beat Bisbing and one by finish and
you've got them in a rear naked choke and put them to sleep.
I mean he's still a giant star.
However he hasn't fought in a while vacated at title.
It doesn't have the title anymore.
So it's not as big of a deal to the public size when his sit down.
It is,
it is.
People are dumb as shit man.
Yeah.
The funny thing to me is like,
I always feel like,
and,
and I always feel like a lot of these mechanisms,
title shots,
rankings,
belts,
uh,
you know,
Twitter beefs.
They weren't intended to be there as a short term solution to give people a
talking point until they saw how,
till they got deeply invested in connected.
Right.
And I think that was,
but yet somehow these sort of extra outside distractions became the focus.
Who the fuck cares?
Who's the number eight guy?
And who cares if these guys are mad at each other on Twitter and the belt itself
as a mechanism for discussion.
What matters is the fight.
And,
and I know that it's like,
yeah,
but you're obsessed with fighting most people,
if you show them what's really going on there and contextualize the fact that
these two human beings have dedicated their life and take an all of the
knowledge in human history to put on the line in this moment of,
of severe intensity and consequence,
he won't care as much about whether somebody has an interim title,
you won't know
you won't and you won't.
But the average Joe blow by a paper view once a year is going to care.
Maybe.
Well,
I mean that's the idea behind stripping Tony Ferguson.
Yeah,
I mean,
why,
why strip?
I'm why,
why takeaways?
Interim title,
let them keep the interim title.
If you want to strip Connor,
just strip Connor,
that's trip Connor.
And then Tony's obviously going to go through surgery.
Tony didn't do anything wrong.
He fell and hurt himself.
But I think at the root of it is the filicides is an incorrect philosophical
belief.
So when I,
if I talked to people at the UFC and I talked to them periodically,
um,
and I'll discuss something with them about,
you know,
and it's generally at different times been like,
hey man,
you can see the work that I'm doing and you can see people like it,
could I contribute something x or y and then I'll mention,
you know,
they will then say,
well,
you know,
you've got like a really unique way of approaching it.
We think,
you know,
we got so many casual fans watching on,
on Fox or on these TV stations.
It's just such a casual audience.
And I think about it,
it's like nobody questions at the,
the percentage of people that are a casual fan that is watching anything is very
close to zero.
Very close to zero.
Yeah.
Because the casual,
the,
the not actively choosing what to watch is being on a Netflix search or is
somebody puts something on and I go in and see what the rock is cooking in his
kitchen,
you know,
or I said,
what's your dog's name and the Gold Dog Marshall.
I go and see what fucking Joe is feeding Marshall.
Nobody's watching something they're not interested in ever in our society,
we are all conscious,
uh,
constantly and consciously choosing what we consume at all times.
And if we're sitting there,
whether our boyfriend or girlfriend or husband or wife and they're watching it
were somewhere else,
by feeding this nonexistent casual audience and really believing they exist
despite all the evidence that there was no such thing,
you are now giving less,
uh,
importance to the,
your actual audience who is ready to go deeper,
ready to see something more meaningful,
ready to be brought somewhere different.
There is no casual audience of almost anything in our modern world.
I like what you're saying,
but I disagree because people are watching and they don't know what the fuck
they're watching.
I've done it with people.
I've,
I've unfortunately watch fights over friends houses before cause I happened to
be there and then,
you know,
there'll be people sitting around watching a,
why doesn't he just do this?
But they still chose to watch it.
They still may not pay attention,
but they made that choice.
Let's say they're barely paying attention,
they don't know what the fuck they're watching.
So a guy like you comes in talking about artistry and all this and they,
I think you are great.
I love your approach,
but I think your approach in their eyes is a little bit too esoteric and complex
and maybe it'd be balanced out better with someone like me.
Yeah.
Yes.
But you know what I mean?
100% and as a result we're not over,
especially the last sort of year or so I've looked at it like,
you know,
trying to force something like I'm not,
I'm not sort of happily saying that I would be,
I would be in a relationship with you and accept what you are.
I'm saying I think we should be in a relationship only I want to change you and
that's not right.
Yes.
I'm like,
I'm literally saying,
I'm not saying put a role here.
Tell me what that role you need and I'll do it.
I'm actually saying I think it should be different and that's why it's not a
good fit.
And that's why I say a one championship is a more logical fit for me because
it's younger and it's in its evolution,
but still growing
think I agree with you,
but I think it goes back to the money cause I think there's so much money
involved in the UFC that they have to make money every month.
I mean it's,
it's there,
it's there in a tricky situation.
It's like,
like if you're a guy and you make 500 bucks a week and you really like this car,
God damn that corvette is so nice.
I really like it.
Well,
how much is the lease?
The lease is $1,000 a month,
but you only make $2,000 a month.
How are you going to do that while if I only pay 500 bucks a month in rent,
I can kind of pull it off.
Right?
Like he,
I guess he can,
but you got to watch every penny and you gotta be cautious and I think you could
put yourself in these traps and then you have to like really micromanage
everything you do.
Like we've got to make money but we got to make money,
but we got to make money instead of we got to do what we like and put together
what we like and do the best possible version of what we like.
Like a perfect example is like this podcast.
I don't have a boss.
There's no overhead.
I don't have,
I mean I have a couple employees.
It's very easy.
There's no worries,
so I don't give a fuck if I have you on to talk about stuff or a leap expert or
I'm not going to have anybody on that.
I don't,
I'm not interested in talking to because,
and I'll talk about whatever the fuck I want to.
I don't,
I don't think,
God,
I know.
I don't know if people are going to be interested in this.
I need that advertising money.
I need to say if you,
because of that.
I think it's one of the reasons why the show has been successful because it
honestly represents my thinking.
It's like I am allowed to pursue my interests and have these conversations and
let it be pure.
I think if the UFC took that exact approach,
I think the product would be better.
And I think if they had someone like you breaking down the artistry of specific
techniques,
the air quote casual fan would be more educated and they would learn more about
it.
I mean,
and you get some of that from Dominick Cruz when he does his breakdowns on Fox
and some of the other fighters who do breakdowns.
And um,
when Daniel Cormier AA does wrestling breakdowns,
breakdowns,
specific techniques of why they work and why they don't work and what someone's
doing,
right or wrong,
you get educated,
you know,
and I tried to do the best I can to when it comes to the ground in particular,
which is what I think is the most confusing aspect of MMA for the casual fan.
But,
um,
I think we should approach the f the entire sport in the,
the,
the most illuminating way possible.
And I think a guy like you and your approach is very valuable.
And I love your breakdowns.
Thanks man.
I'm a big fan of him.
It's why retweet him all the time.
I just think that you have a a very unique and passionate and it not just
passionate approach but it's genuine.
Like I know you,
I've talked to you when the cameras are not on and you are just as interested in
this.
I really am.
And I think we're just going through,
thank you by the way man.
I think where we're going through whatever you're doing,
if you're trying to seek some kind of mastery and if you realize you're really
early in it,
you can do it by studying yoga.
Some people do,
some people do it.
They,
they're in,
they go to church twice a week.
You're just looking to try to grow.
And if you do it with something that you're deeply fascinated and eventually you
kind of learn about connections and all things,
you know,
it's the study of martial arts or the study of Yoga or the study of jazz or
whatever teaches you about connections in all things.
And my life is so fucking good.
And,
and these little moments where I'm like,
I don't know why these guys,
I don't work for them.
That doesn't make any sense.
It doesn't make any sense for me to think that because I get up in the morning
and I sit in my car,
I make my wife and I coffee and I sit in my kitchen and I fucking analyze
fighting.
I sit down and I look at it and I look for moments and I look for things.
I think people will find fascinating.
I look for things that'll teach us something about life and I look for these and
I'm make them.
Then when I make them,
people seem to like them and then that gets me jobs commentating where I fly off
and I get to,
I mean I got it so fucking gun to try to square peg my way into a large
corporation because years back I dreamed about working there.
Sometimes you change your dream,
sometimes it's okay to change your route and find the world changes.
Constantly
be afraid to be flexible and you know the,
the idea of holding onto a dream for your entire life despite your interest is
pretty ridiculous.
Yeah.
I mean there's things that I wanted to do when I was younger.
I don't want to do anymore.
It doesn't,
you know,
you should follow your interest period.
Yeah.
And if they change your change as you change and grow.
I mean these,
like I talked about my waning love for talk one doe when I realized that it
wasn't really the right way to go.
Well when I first started doing it,
I thought it was the most effective martial art.
Once I realized it wasn't,
I lost interest,
I lost interest in competing in it.
I just,
it didn't seem like the thing to do anymore.
And I think that as you grow as a human being,
you're in,
you should have other interests.
I mean,
and I think the ones that are the most intriguing in the most passionate,
uh,
are you the,
you're the,
you're the most passionate of theirs.
They're going to give you the most reward if you pursue them.
If you're more passionate about music,
then you are about accounting.
But you decided to stick with accounting because it's what's paying your bills
and like,
man,
that's a dark road.
That's a soul suck and road.
You're going to go,
yeah,
down.
Sit,
it feels scary in for somebody in that setting to change because in the short
run it will be painful.
But in the long run it will be so valuable and less painful.
Yeah.
Listen,
20 years have way less pain is such a great trade for two years of pain.
But if you're that guy with that corvette that you got that lease on and you
could barely fucking make those payments,
you can not take any chances.
You have to just work those extra hours.
Well,
if I just put in two hours of overtime every day,
that's still only 10 hours of work a day.
But that was two hours at 20 bucks an hour and a little out.
We started doing those calculations.
And that's how you,
that's how you get fucked.
And that's how you get trapped.
And next thing you know,
you've got a family and you've got kids and you definitely can't move and you
got a mortgage and you definitely ain't pursuing any music dreams.
Now,
motherfucker,
that's true.
And this is,
this is the trap that life leads.
Yeah.
You know,
um,
I watched,
so I do a one man show now.
So I built where the friend,
I built a one man show.
It's like,
oh,
we're going to theater setting,
right?
Yeah.
Like how do you do that?
Do you use video?
How it is for,
we put it for um,
drunk tedtalks right.
So it's four story driven parts of life that uh,
take you on a bit of an in theory and in practice.
So far people seem to be inspired or find it,
you know,
compelling.
And people have cried Adam them before,
which is really quite moving.
But I go to a dog gate,
they may be shit especially.
Yeah.
Um,
but uh,
I,
I did it with,
so I decided I wanted to do that.
I decided I want to get up and tell stories and hopefully a fun,
entertain people or find them,
inspire them or take them somewhere.
And I did it.
Partly I watched your show and then that would have never in a million years.
So when I saw you in Vegas would never in a million years thought I could do
that because it's clearly a lifetime of training and development and improvement
and trial and error and thousands and thousands of repetitions.
And you look at that and you don't look at an Olympic gymnast and say I can do
that.
And that's kind of,
so I didn't think of it at all.
But then I saw Brendan do his show and it was awesome and I realized he only
started working on this two years ago.
You know what I mean?
And all he represents is hard,
hard work,
sacrifice and drive to learn.
And that's possible.
Yeah.
Which shop is doing is what I said to him as you are essentially using an
athlete's work ethic and applying it to an art form.
And that's what's awesome about him.
He's a funny guy who realize like,
I can do standup,
I just need to put the time in and you know,
I've seen that guy kill,
I mean kill.
And he's been doing comedy for like two years,
you know,
that
is inspiring.
That should in,
you should be aware when you see that,
that that means something you work on for only a couple of years as possible,
if you're driven and smart and,
and really committed.
And that's what I took out of his shell.
Plus he explained to me the process.
So I decided I'm doing it right.
So I booked about five months ahead in Winnipeg because there was a UFC in
Winnipeg and that's my hometown to do a small theater.
And I'm like,
okay,
five months.
And I'm like,
what the fuck do I do?
So I called up a good friend of mine gray.
I'm just you,
when you booked it,
you didn't have to have a show.
I didn't have the shell.
Maybe months yourself.
Yeah.
So,
and I cut,
but I had one plan that was going to call up.
My friend Graham is the door who is a playwright and um,
and a writer for vice and a bunch of other stuff and uh,
and very smart and interesting and we're good friends,
but we have very different perspectives.
And I said,
I booked this show.
It's in six months.
I need 40 minutes.
It's gotta be eye.
And he's,
he has told some of my stories and vice before getting drunk with sumo wrestlers
and different,
different stories.
And so he's,
how much do you weigh?
A one 56 and you got drunk with sumo wrestler?
Scary.
Oh,
scary.
It was really like,
it was joyous.
Like it was,
you've never seen anything like this became big though.
Yeah.
Oh,
you should see it.
So Byamba do you know who'd be is?
He's like,
okay.
So if you ever see us Sumal on TV that's beyond.
So he's the guy like in the Geico commercial do I being a figure skater,
tiger woods of sumo wrestling.
And he is a genius.
He's a world champion,
but he's also an entertainer.
So he lives in Hollywood and he's very,
very blips here.
Yeah,
yeah.
He is sumo Russell's,
yeah,
there he is.
Yeah,
he is from Mongolia.
But he spends a great deal of time here working as a television personality and
an actor and whatever.
But he's still just look fat.
Oh,
he's got it looks jacked.
Like go to that one where he's doing that muscle pose.
Don't worry there.
Yeah.
See that's like those shoulder muscles through all that fat.
That guy looks like a tank.
Well,
people don't realize,
but underneath there is like you or underneath there is like Tj Dillashaw.
You know what I mean?
There is muscular person underneath all those additional layers of fat and
fleshing skin.
There was a,
there was a powerful athlete,
a real benefit and being not fat.
Uh,
yeah.
Force power generation like momentum,
the ability,
I mean,
if the other guy is that big and our goal is just to smash into each other until
one of us has taken from the platform,
right.
You're not that big,
it's going to be very difficult.
Right.
So it's like an arms race of size over generations where they just got bigger
and bigger out of necessity.
Because if you're bigger,
I mean,
what am I going to do?
Uh,
we could in theory,
maybe I could use your size against your,
I could use technique and strategy and smarts to take you off,
but I could be big and also to that,
right,
right.
So why not v also big.
So it,
it arms raised to that point and there are little guys,
but uh,
but to watch this guy that's with them,
then he got killed.
He was an impractical jokers.
But yeah,
beyond that is like he's the most famous sumo guy in the world and I got wasted
with him at the world combat games and Saint Petersburg,
Russia.
So I got to commentate it.
Right.
So I was in Saint Petersburg and I absolutely love,
I've found a niche where I get to commentate like real traditional martial arts,
a fair bit of done taekwondo and karate at the Pan Am Games.
And I did the world so much championships or the world combat games.
I do the World Woo Shu Championships,
which is Kung Fu and Sanda.
And so I've carved out this niche where I get called for these and develop
expertise in these different areas and get to experience them.
And see the little details that change when you change something.
And so I got to commentate sumo and then after he seemed to like me and he's
kind of like,
you were drink and it was something that like,
it's he drink vodka while you were in Russia to Russia.
So I love Russia.
I do.
I really do.
I love the Russians.
I love that our view of combat and of artists,
martial arts and and stuff,
they're very straight.
Like,
you know,
when you negotiate to commentate or to do some work that just straight,
this is what we can pay you.
This is what we expect of you.
If you do that,
we're all going to be happy.
Like it's very,
very little bullshit.
Uh,
Frank Mir does commentary for them over there,
right?
Yes,
he does.
Yeah.
He's very good.
Frank Mir,
I would hope that someone would hire him in America.
They can't afford them because I wasn't getting paid way too well in Russia.
In Russia.
Really?
No kidding.
Yeah.
For him.
He said that's why he couldn't do a deal with [inaudible]
and his deal with ACB,
who he loves and respects things,
become sort of partners in there with uh,
with,
uh,
Mr [inaudible] who runs it,
where frank is now a part partner of the presentation of it.
Went for American shows.
He'll be part,
he'll be part promoter.
And I think Frank May even get away from some of the commentary.
As much as he's good at it and loves it.
I think he's interested in some of the other aspects of it now,
you know.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
they pay very well.
They and they pay the athletes very,
very well.
You can be a guy that had a couple of UFC fights or a belt or a fighter too.
They'll give you 60,000 us cash in your hand in an envelope at the end of it.
Yeah.
That's great.
Well,
it's always great that fighters have more options,
you know.
And uh,
I know Bella tour has become a viable option to a lot of fighters.
You know,
like guys like Ryan Bader or making good money over there now.
And,
and you know,
Roy McDonald obviously who's the champion now.
I just think,
uh,
we need more of those.
You know,
I,
I know that Oscar de la Hoya is getting into the mix now,
but just the approach that he's making,
it seems to me to be ridiculous.
The old school promote us approach,
get some big name and then invest all your time in that big fight.
But it's,
yeah,
that's the same thing you were just talking about the UFC,
the challenge they face now is that we need another big one.
We need another big one.
It just seems like that
that approach.
Like we just,
we know,
okay,
if this wasn't the upper,
would this be the ideal approach?
No,
it's never the ideal approach.
The ideal approach is to do the best fights possible.
The ideal approach is not necessarily to make the most money or to have the like
the most spectacular thing.
Like,
like when they were really promoting Ronda Rousey and the rematch with a,
or the fight with Amanda Nunez and didn't promote Nunez at all.
I was,
I,
you know,
I was like,
this is my huge Ronda Rousey fan.
Everybody knows that.
Um,
I think she's a,
she's a legend.
I mean,
what she did for women's MMA,
she essentially was the reason why the UFC decided to have women's MMA was one
woman.
Everyone's running around and fighting.
Now.
I was here that day.
It
just passed her by and it happened so quick,
you know.
But Amanda Nunez,
I was thinking even before Holly Holm Beater,
Amanda Nunez was the big threat.
I'm like,
that girl could knock you fucking dead with one punch.
She is such a ruthless striker and she's a Brazilian jujitsu black belt.
I'm like,
this is a terrible matchup for Rhonda.
I thought,
cause Ron does hands,
although good,
you know,
and getting better and you know,
really was starting to look like a polished striker.
Still doesn't have nearly the kind of power that Nunez has and the ability that
I could Nunez Nunez is,
she can take it as well as receive it.
We just seen Rhonda sort of have these blitz moments with like Batchko Hey,
uh,
and you know,
and kind of Sarah Mann bricks just smashed through.
But when you see the overall game like versus Holly Home,
then you've got to see all this.
There's a lot of limitations here and trying to smash through the bricks if the
bricks aren't there and the bricks head kick you,
you know what I mean?
There's,
there's a lot going on there.
So we're,
we're seeing the layers upon layers upon layer.
So what happens after you get to the first layer?
Oh well you don't have a second layer.
You're your,
this is your layer,
your layer straight forward,
move ahead.
And you know,
coaching is to blame as well.
There's a,
there's a lot of things there,
but the fact that they weren't even promoting Amanda Nunez,
you have the very first ever openly gay women's MMA champion in the UFC
era comes out and is interesting aspect
and she's a fun girl.
She's interesting,
you know,
and she's a fucking killer man.
She's a fucking killer.
And that you showed it in that fight.
They had an opportunity to make another star.
Instead,
they didn't make this other star.
And then you look at her most recent paper view,
I heard the numbers were abysmal.
Vallely I heard,
see if you can find out what the numbers were because someone told me,
I think it was shopped,
told me there were 85,000 people view by wow.
Which is scary.
You should be at this point you have to stop and wonder is there anything we
could do strategically different?
Like just because something worked all the way along in any business or in
anything you're doing,
there might be a time to take a slightly different approach or to change one of
the fundamental beliefs of how we do business or something.
You know what I mean?
What you can't do is just go,
well,
hopefully the next one will be good.
I mean,
you watch that happen all the time to some massive change in your business or in
life and that change,
uh,
at first people deny that it's there,
right?
They deny it and then they say it's a niche and then they say it's a blip.
And then by the time that it's actually in the heat of something scary or
challenging happening,
you've wasted two or three years that you could've used adapting to be ready for
it.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
No.
Do you know what you mean?
Yeah.
I mean,
I think that what would you got to do when you have a champion that has
spectacular results?
Like Amanda knows you've got to hype the shit out of her.
Invest,
invest,
hype the shit out of her.
And that would have made the Ronda Rousey fight.
I think even bigger if you show her smashing me should Tate,
you show her,
you know,
smashing Sarah McMahon,
you show what she's capable of like she's a fucking once
for sure.
For sure.
And you talked to Mike Brown or anyone there who's been around the greats and
that they talk about it.
But this level now where they are the brilliance of where what we've seen.
It's another example if you think that only fighting to stand up when you're in
guard is right.
Uh,
or only keeping somebody down as the game.
And the only thing you have to worry about us,
they'll stand up,
they'll submit you,
right?
Like as soon as you don't recognize where you are in,
in change of the,
the river of life and time,
you sometimes get fucked up.
And,
and uh,
you know,
it's a,
it's a fascinating thing.
I know I literally was just in Singapore and I just spent days with this
company,
but they see the world differently.
They're strategy is simply,
they're a,
they're a values based company that believes in the values of these things and
tries to,
to show people and share martial artists reef for the greater good.
And it's not some business,
it's what they truly believe.
They truly are going about and making choices.
And when chattery says,
I would not hire Conor McGregor because he represents,
he's dead fucking serious people who represent his ideas is and what he sees,
and I shouldn't speak for him at all.
He's a brilliant man.
By the way,
this guy,
he's a chef,
he was a homeless kid with,
with a single parent that later became educated.
And then moved to America and went to Harvard and then started managing a
corporate funds and became a Moitai champion.
And this is all easily documented.
This is who that individual is.
And he's lived that life based on honor,
respect,
you know,
um,
teamwork excellence,
that mind,
that is what built that company.
And one is a billion dollar company now it's $1 billion company that's in 1.7
billion homes in Asia.
This isn't some mythological idea.
This is a guy who's built a massive company based around these values and that's
a different thing.
He's been,
what does he say about common?
Oh,
sorry.
Yeah,
I go off on this.
No,
it's cool.
Uh,
so he looks at it as the things that he says and the way that,
and again,
I shouldn't speak for him,
this was the,
what I've gathered,
throwing things and creating conflict and controversy as your currency is not
something to be proud of.
It's an interesting,
we were putting it as your currency.
Yeah,
yeah.
I get it.
You know,
and that sounds because,
and I'm not quite all the,
although I've drank the Koolaid,
I believe in what they're doing and I see it as real,
not only cause my values line up with it,
but I think they are going to grow dramatically as a result of some of these,
the way they see the world.
But not only that,
but I'm still also immersed here and I like Connor,
I think of Connor,
I worked for TSN because Connor fell out of a march to a red carpet to shake my
hand while the my boss was watching.
You know what I mean?
Yeah,
yeah.
Like the great,
some of the most interesting moments I've had are with that guy and some of the
most interesting,
you know,
many dozens of hours of trying to figure out what's happening in research and
growth has happened by studying that guy.
And I see his,
the games that he is willing to play as part of his strategy for success as a
fighter and success trying to be successful for his family and his future.
I see it all connected so I don't dislike him,
but I respect this,
this idea that conflict and controversy are not good for us.
I understand.
But I also understand
psychological warfare and I think the condor is a master of that.
And that has a huge factor in victory.
I mean,
this is something Miyamoto Musashi use to his advantage.
Um,
you know,
when you,
if you read the book of five rings,
he,
what Connor's doing is fucking with people's heads the point where they,
he has space in their head and then Conor goes into the cage,
like loose as a goose,
relaxed and calm.
So he's letting you know,
I don't give a fuck about you,
but you give a fuck about me and I'm going to fuck you up right now.
And you're like,
no,
you're not.
You better not.
You can't,
I can't.
This is too much.
And Josie Aldo is the perfect example,
although was so out of composure a although charged at him with that just
leaping left hook and just got fucking waylaid on the way in.
And Eddie Alvarez,
the greatest game day performer,
one of the Great Game Day performance we've ever seen.
And I talked to Ldl,
that is one of my favorites and I admire and am inspired by Eddie Alvarez,
Michael Chandler too.
You know those two are like the same guy I lost.
You know,
Eddie was like,
the plan was to wrestle a lot and stay at distance and barely at all and I
stayed at distance almost the whole time and barely Russell like he's just like,
it was real like an I.
And by not accepting it was real coming in and suddenly you find yourself in
there and it's real and you feel different and your,
you know,
your mind is working differently and your hormones are working differently and
who you are and that moment is different and you're like,
holy fuck,
it's real.
Had I prepared for it to be real?
I could be in a different state right now,
but I denied that this was going to be real and now it's fucking real.
Santa Claus is real.
It's real.
I also think you got clipped early and I think that's a factor.
You know,
you get caught on the chin like that and your legs give out real quick and you,
you're just,
your brain doesn't work right and know your body doesn't work right anymore.
I think that's a factor.
The ability that Connor has to land those sharp shots that come out of nowhere
and blitz you and come at you so fast and just drop those shots on you.
I mean his left hand is a fucking laser beam and that's so good planning it.
That's what that is.
The definition of it.
He's so good at landing that shot and he's also good at landing a bunch of other
shit too.
Man,
me pick you apart.
He's a,
he's a real dynamo.
I just,
I hate to see things like what happened in New York and Brooklyn and he threw
the Dolly at the bus and smashed the window.
It's like,
so it's so fucking stupid.
All that thuggish shit running in with a bunch of other guys and everyone's
screaming at w was what?
What did he do?
He smacked your friend in the face because your friend friend was talking shit.
So you know,
I mean,
and even the way smacked him was pretty general.
You know what I mean?
And Artem called him a coward and he said didn't,
he doesn't find Connor's a real fighters.
Like,
listen man,
he's rushing.
You're rushing.
You guys got to sort this out on your own.
That is how they sorted it out.
And look,
it was a pretty calm sorting out in my opinion.
I mean they didn't stomp him,
they didn't beat his ass.
But once we get to that point,
I mean I get
it.
They,
yeah,
once we,
you're doing something and I'm responding what's he responds that happens every
day in gangs,
in wars,
in Northern Ireland and Ireland and all types of religions that's been going on
forever.
Nobody ever wins when that happens,
it just goes,
it just perpetuates it.
And when you watch it and then there'll be a lot of people,
you see this scenario and like Habib's fans or friends or supporters and condos
and they're like,
oh,
he did this.
They're both wrong.
And nobody,
everybody always,
when somebody does something bad to somebody else,
they almost always feel like something was but done bad to them.
Very few people instigate that was perceived.
Something happened.
They perceive a slight and you know some people you do one thing to them and
then they're like,
okay mother fucker,
now it's to eternity.
Well that doesn't make any sense either.
You look like a fool,
you know,
you just can't throw a dolly at a bus.
No.
You know,
filled with other fighters because it's so selfish.
I mean all those people that got caught,
you know,
I mean Ray Borg got cuts in his eyes.
I mean this is the whole thing is a disaster.
So my theory based on bits of information that,
that we have is that Connor,
on some level,
it really,
I mean it reinforces constantly.
If he,
if your kid does something terrible that we know is bad and he'd give him candy
every time they're going to do some batch yet give her candy.
Every time she does something,
that reward conn has been rewarded.
He gets richer,
more famous,
more influential,
the belts.
And he's been given candy every time he's done this.
And it works.
And I mean,
there is parallels in the political system in America.
There's parallels all over the world that by acting out in these strange ways,
it's so bizarre and unsettling that we reward it.
You know that name for a band?
Candy for Babby.
Yeah,
that'd be,
there's a punk band,
but that's what's happening.
Right?
And so now we take it and he's,
and then you add the strategy element that you're talking about,
right?
So he's looking at it and it's like,
okay,
uh,
Habib would be a great fight.
I'd like to fight in Russia.
He likes challenges is as hard,
but let's do it.
Now,
if I create some viral controversy,
which I did with,
with Paulie,
Mala nausea,
who's a have you,
do you know Polly?
I've only talked to him on Twitter.
I don't know.
I fucking love Polly.
And I like him as a dude.
I really do.
Um,
uh,
but,
so he created that in the work and it's like,
okay,
whether,
how on what level he's strategizing this,
he's like,
let's go do some pushing.
And shoving with Habib and has guys some given the finger,
it'll be caught on cameras.
What?
What one thing we know about Connor,
he's always late,
always late.
He didn't plan to get there when they're on a bus.
He planned to get there when they're in the hall.
He planned to get there.
When does a bunch of people around it's security and it's easy to manage little
push and little shove in a couple of cameras and all of a sudden his $5 million
pay day is a $12 million payday in Russia and everybody's going crazy.
It'll work.
It's brilliant.
But he's late.
So he shows up there on the bus.
Now the cameras are out and what's he going to do?
He's got to perform.
He came there to perform it,
came there to do a thing.
We showed up and now it,
now it goes sideways and that's the most likely scenario is that it was a,
let's do it.
It'll be,
it'll feel right for us as,
as defending our friend,
but also it will have some inherent value in the cameras come out and nobody
will get hurt.
Yeah.
Well,
I think you're probably right there.
It's got to get,
he's got a good point,
but obviously it's a terrible thing to do and stupid.
You know,
there's,
there's a way to manage that,
but then is people say,
well,
you know,
now it becomes like the WWE and you know,
there's,
there's people that love real fighting that have a real hard time with these
fake WWE style scenarios where you know that whether it's Colby Covington,
yeah.
You know,
like he did a promo recently.
We had a,
a girl by the pool and the girl sat in his lap and she was like,
obviously had a plan script and it seemed kind of Corny people.
There's people who think that's great and there's people fucking hate it.
I'm the hate it.
Yeah.
I'm the heated too.
I don't,
I mean,
I don't have a real problem with pro wrestling.
I joke around about it all the time and I get the fact that people like it.
I don't like that kind of shit bleeding into MMA.
I think it's dumb
bad.
It's also,
I mean,
again,
if you're viewing it as inspiring artistry with which there are lessons to
fucking live your life on one hand and on,
and then that's how I truly see it,
an interface with it and experience it and,
and share it and,
and want to see people get to feel that.
And then on the other hand,
you're sort of putting together these weird scripts to sell pay per views,
but I mean wrestling that stuff that came up in wrestling because it isn't
inherently real.
It needed those extras.
It needed all that stuff.
If we understood how brilliant Colby Covington was,
if we understood how brilliant of a combat sportsman he was,
he wouldn't have to do that.
But he's doing that and that's what got him a title shot.
Right?
So on the other side,
the other side of the coin,
we're wrong.
You want to know if we understood he would get it based on that.
But we don't understand.
We,
we the royal,
we don't get it.
It's like I'll see people talk about fighting after and there'll be like there
and some people's,
this is their idea of covering a fight and our fans or people and everybody's
entitled to their own thing.
But they'll be like,
yeah,
the,
the show was kind of a lackluster fair.
Not a lot of finishes.
Fuck.
Could you have 20 brilliant athletes have it interact and some that your opinion
of how it did or it didn't excite you is super valid to you.
But that's not what we were watching that.
Right.
But what I'm talking about is like what got him a title shot?
My title shot is being an asshole because of the reality that we live in.
That's what he had to do.
Right,
right.
I mean like what he did in Brazil after he beat Damien,
Maia said this is a shit hole.
That's literally what got him the title shot.
I mean if you really stop and think about it,
he's ranked,
what does he ranked number three?
He's only beaten Maya and he's beaten some other people,
but it terms of top 10 contenders in terms of like real world class fighters,
there's a lot of guys that are out there that have fucked up a lot of other
people like wonder boy.
It was like,
how is this guy fighting for the title and for an interim title?
And I'm not.
After he's gone through those two big fights with Tyron Woodley,
beaten,
Jorge Mas,
doll,
beaten all these debate and Johnny Hendricks beaten all of these different
fighters.
Colby beat Damien Maia and that's the really the big name on his resume and
yeah,
but it's also because he's going to be fighting Hofeld dos Anjos who's a
Brazilian.
He said a lot of stupid shit about Brazil.
Brazilians hate.
And Brazil's a giant market.
It's an easy sell and this is,
this is what he's talked himself into and it's a tough fight.
Don't make no mistake about it.
The guy that beat Damien Maia is a tough fucking fighter.
Colby A.
Yeah.
And again,
you talked to Dean Thomas or Mike Brown and they two years back when they were
taught.
And I would,
I'm the Jorge Mass fuddled freak,
right?
That's one of those special artists to me.
And so I'll be asking,
you know,
like when I'll see Mike or a dean or these guys or anybody around that,
I'm like,
hey,
how's,
how's Jorge doing?
What's he working on?
What is he changes and they'll talk on,
he's always training with Colby.
He's a fuck.
He's a deadly,
he's one of the greats in the Jim Hill.
The two of them are first there last to leave.
Like you've heard about how good he was under that public surface.
And I,
but I see what you're saying,
based on what we've created,
he doesn't have much of a choice if he wants to achieve his goals other than
doing it this way.
And the guys who are good at it,
jail,
obviously the jail is like really good at one of the best,
whatever greatness.
And he's an entertainer.
Yeah.
And don't you love jail?
I love chatting fucking love child.
And yet this is something I find distasteful about this art form is that game
yet somehow channel is so lovable.
I love child.
Right?
But it's because there's a natural love of that kind of performance and Colby
and I've played around with it a little bit when I played in a band where you
would be rude and arrogant and play that kind of game.
It's not,
it's hard.
It's hard.
It's hard to do.
It's hard when it's hard to be convincing.
It's also hard to be hated all the time.
That's real.
Like you,
you will feel the hatred of the all Brazilians who truly hate you even though
you were playing a game.
Getting real about that shit.
Zillions are extremely patriotic,
very nationalistic.
You Talk Shit about Brazil,
you better duck.
Yeah.
Hey,
they know the boomerang.
And in fact,
even if you were talked to somebody like a stereotypically passionate person,
we're talking about here and you said it's a joke and they'd be like,
you can't make that joke right there.
Point isn't that.
I don't care if he was kidding.
The fact that he was willing to do that is so disrespectful to all of us that we
must slit his throat.
And that's what they'll chant when he goes to walk out there and they mean it.
They do mean it.
But meanwhile
he just doubled down.
He didn't give a fuck even after he got hit in the head with the boomerang,
still doubling down,
swinging for the fences.
What other choice,
I guess,
look,
it has got him to the dance and if he wins two Saturdays from this one or one
Saturday,
how's it going next one,
his tail and Wonderboy.
Yeah,
that's another one to talk about it.
Yeah.
But if he wins,
if he wins,
he will have a belt.
I mean,
it's not the real belt.
I mean it's an interim belt,
but it guarantees them a shot at the real belt.
Yeah.
You know,
so it gets very interesting.
So he's like,
I know that I my look at these sort of systems and the areas around that I have
a negative bias.
Like,
you know,
it's not about that.
And I know that's,
that's negative to me about the belt or the rankings or beef or whatever.
But the belt cannot mean what it meant before.
By the nature of once upon a time there were only ever 27 of them and now
there's been 340 of them.
By nature it cannot be as valuable as it once was.
Right.
And when there's two in yours,
it inherently cannot have the value because scarcity is where value comes from.
Yeah.
It's really just a promotional tool.
It's a marketing tool and it's a,
it's a questionable one.
You know,
there's,
there's a real good argument that it's a bad idea to have these interim title
shots because you know,
like,
okay,
well what's the rules?
You just decide when to have an interim shot,
especially with a guy like Tony Ferguson,
right?
He Beats Kevin Lee Spectacular Phi triangles and off lost to nobody after that
last one.
One the interim title and then you strip it because he falls down during a
promotion.
He trips on some wires.
I mean this isn't,
I mean it's not like you went and did something stupid outside of fighting.
He was just doing a promotion and tripped on some wires.
So freak accident and that really,
if we move away all of the things and just look at the systems at play and how
and why it's there.
If he was,
if he had another 2 million Instagram followers,
that would not happen.
You're right and that's it.
You're right.
It's strictly that that is true,
right?
Yeah.
I mean Tony was a giant,
huge star.
There's no way they would strip them.
No.
Yeah,
no,
but by not being,
cause he's a character.
He's,
he's an odd ball.
He has a unique,
he's one of a kind.
We should celebrate that.
He's one of a kind.
He's an individual.
He's different than everybody.
That's awesome.
If you're going to strip Connor,
which they did and you have,
could be fight for the title,
the true title and you know,
look,
that's arguable whether or not you should do that should probably be two interim
fights or to an interim titles,
which will be cool.
He's not beating the champion.
If he didn't beat the champion,
he beat ally Quinta.
How is him beating owl?
I acquaint to a more valid than Tony beating Kevin Lee.
That's crazy.
It isn't.
It's crazy.
It doesn't make any sense.
I mean,
not no taking anything away against Al,
but Al took that fight on unfucking one day's notice.
Yeah.
So it's even more ridiculous and awesome and awesome and awesome.
That was a great fight.
It was
really fun.
Yeah.
Well there's,
there's a bunch of,
yeah,
it was really fun and I like,
Quinta is another one of these guys.
How can you not be inspired?
Seeing a guy like life is traveling along and all of a sudden you have this one
shot at something,
you're not ready.
You don't have,
you haven't prepared in the ways you want,
but you know what?
I'm going to go for it.
Right.
That's a life lesson.
And there's also like I,
there's a forgiving nature to this machine that is kind of admirable.
Like Alice created problems.
Al Has had conflict with that company and then they were still like,
you know what?
Let's do this area.
The
did it though.
They did it because they wouldn't,
they wouldn't use Paul Felder the fucking athletic commission.
That's all ridiculous,
ridiculous.
I mean all their wisdom,
they decided that Paul Felder isn't ranked high enough.
Like
you don't know shit.
I don't even know where rankings come from,
which is a bunch of people like hanging out to kind of watch,
fighting a bunch of,
making an arbitrary choice and then combining it.
Like,
do you know what,
um,
what a first class noticer is.
Have you ever heard this term a fa?
So a first class noticer in business or any number of things as somebody who
over times you start to see the different systems and how they interact with
each other and you are one,
you clearly are a first class noticer.
You see big picture,
small picture,
combine how the outside right now you're like,
well the,
the commission did this but Paul felter did that.
Rankings are this way and you're able to pull all these things together and look
at it.
Right?
And if you look at any of these things from that perspective of how the systems
all work,
the whole thing barely makes sense.
You know what I mean?
Paul Felder is brilliant.
Paul,
if he's a dangerous fight day,
including Khabib and committed and mentally strong and a striver,
worldclass striker and his striking his fucking deadly.
And he's not just a striker in terms of punching like owl.
He's a really nasty kicker.
I mean,
Al can kick.
Yep,
no doubt about it.
But Paul was a bit more achieved in,
in his,
uh,
he's got more weapons,
more complex,
spinning back fists and elbows and knees and nasty leg kicks and you know,
went three hard rounds with Barboza and went toe to toe with them.
I mean,
he's that good.
He's that good on it
and smart.
Yeah,
he's,
he's a great analyst for a such a young one.
But when you look,
so you're like,
how is that possible?
Because that's really hard and it's a different skill set than just being a good
fight this language and being able to rationalize things and all these different
things.
But you look back and he did it on the small leaks,
which he didn't need to do.
He pursued because it was of interest to him.
He pursued it to get good at it because he loved it,
which means he's predisposed to thinking that way.
So now you also have a thinker,
a fighter,
incredibly dangerous striker,
a guy who can play complex games in it and you in your infinite wisdom,
don't think he can fight Habib because somebody somewhere said that he put a
seven next to his name instead of a three.
There was a lot
real,
real problems with the athletic commission and we won't go into depth.
I don't want to cause any problems.
But uh,
they,
they had some real issues.
They're young,
they're new.
Yeah,
there's a lot of nonsense.
It was going on behind the scenes.
But I think that what,
what was interesting about that fight was we got to see al step up.
We got to see Khabib have some issues with striking and you know,
we got to see,
I mean,
what,
what I don't like about it is this whole,
the whole championship thing.
What I don't like about it is he didn't beat the champion to become a champion.
They just sort of like set this fight up.
Al Wasn't preparing for that fight.
He was preparing for a three round fight and then Tony gets stripped.
All those things.
I don't,
yeah,
it because they don't make any sense.
They don't take anything,
make any sense.
Because if we go back to the,
if we have some kind of value root of what we're about other than the necessity
to,
to sell things based on the same marketing that we use,
we wouldn't have to be in that situation,
but we find ourselves there and when you're on,
when you're on the bottom of half guard,
you just have to work your way out of half guard and that's what that machine
has to do and that's what you know Habib has to do and that's,
you got an artificial stand up.
Yeah,
exactly.
Got stood up.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know Wonderboy until,
man,
that's a big fire.
Yeah,
that's a Saturday.
That's fucking,
that's chaos stuff.
Fight is very interesting to me.
I am very,
very,
very interested in that fight.
Me Too.
Yeah.
I want to see what happens when till fights Wonderboy,
because I was stunned by how easily till ran through cowboy and cowboy in all
fairness is not,
in my opinion,
a real one 70 he's a tweener.
I think cowboy would be a one 65 you know,
and I think maybe it,
his struggles to make one 55 maybe she'd be 10 pounds heavier.
And I think that 10 pound weight class thing is real.
I think that's where it should be.
Every 10 pounds.
Darren till is a fucking huge guy.
So Steve,
yeah,
they're both very tall and strong,
but till you know,
regularly is well over a hundred I mean,
well over 200 pounds.
Yeah.
He's walking around at like,
um,
you know,
fucking two oh five and shit and cutting down to one 70 it's a good one,
man.
It's a really,
you know,
there's so many little odd ball variables and unknowns,
right?
Like we literally,
when we go and we look at these,
the more you've studied and analyzed and commentated fighting for 20 years of
your life,
the more you realize how little we actually know.
Like we have about two or seven or 18% of the actual information,
you know what I mean?
And we're trying to work with it and the big one.
So when,
when Cody fought TJ or,
um,
Dominic,
I was like,
I just don't see how he can win.
I don't see how Cody can win.
And then somebody to say,
well,
why did he say that?
He knocked out all these guys?
I'm like,
well yeah,
it's hard to get to Dominic.
And we've never seen evidence of him doing well after those minutes.
The evidence isn't there to see it.
Of course 100% wrong,
but there,
but you have to go by what evidence you have.
What have we seen or what information have we gathered that can allow us to make
a decision to me?
Cody Garbrandt did not have,
there was no evidence he can be Dominic and then boom,
beats up Dominic and you're blown away.
And that's an exciting feeling.
And that is,
I think what's at play here.
Is there any evidence that that Darren till can do what Rory Macdonald couldn't
do and Jorge mass but all couldn't do and get to a guy who has that movement,
that blitz thinking that karate's um,
uh,
those karate instincts we were talking about,
we've seen no real evidence of that.
But that doesn't mean he can't do it.
It doesn't mean he can't do it,
but the evidence isn't there.
I don't know about that.
I was stunned by his ability to close the distance on cowboy,
that nasty left.
Oh,
well they'll be landed over the top.
Yeah.
The way he put them away.
I don't know.
I think that's pretty good evidence that he's a fucking monster.
I agree.
And his fights previous in the UFC as well,
although they didn't have a lot of fanfare behind him,
you know,
stunning results.
And then you talk to people that know him,
you know,
talk to people that know his striking document and people that have seen him in
the gym and understand what he's been through in his life.
And he's a young guy.
I think he's only 25 how old is Darren [inaudible]?
I'm pretty sure he's 25 Celso never lost,
right?
Never.
It's a fucking beast,
man.
Yeah.
And then you see the pictures,
even the 25 years old.
That's wild man.
And but what I'm saying is I would have,
I would not be the slightest bit surprised if he could do it because we've seen
enough over time to know that what a 23 year old is capable of,
they'll see the whole game differently.
They'll see their understanding of where they are in relation to the other guy
is so different that it just on one day,
all of a sudden all these 25 year olds are just so fucking good.
And we don't really have the language to explain why.
You know,
can we just say,
oh,
he was able to close the distance on Stephen Thompson.
If he does,
we'll say yes,
but then the question would be how when nobody else could do it,
how and why could he do it?
And that's always what obsesses me.
If you see him do it,
there is now the explanation isn't,
he was better at closing the distance or his range management was excellent.
Dot.
That's true for a bit.
But then my next question,
the next morning we'll be like,
how the fuck did he do it?
What?
What changed now?
What about the,
the entirety of the game itself,
the systems of the relationships of two fighters.
What changed in such a way because of his behavior and that's where it gets to
me really,
really wild.
Because right now nobody gets to Stephen Thompson and I mean nobody really at
all.
Well Tyron is knocked him down twice about him really badly.
There's 50 minutes,
50 minutes,
and he had like the fight.
Those are the moments in the fight where they engaged.
See the problem with those two Tyron Woodley fights,
Woodley fought
Wonderboy the right way.
That's how you got to fight them.
You don't engage.
And when you do engage,
you've got to be absolutely convinced you're going to land.
And Tyron did and did land and hurt them.
I mean you looked at those two fights.
Tyron is the one who's the wrestler,
but he's also the one that hurt Wonderboy.
Wonderboy never heard tire.
And in those fights,
nope.
Tyron had him very close to being now.
And I just wonder if Wonderboy is starting to slip.
You know,
you got to wonder,
you gotta wonder if all his years of combat sports,
all of his years of kickboxing and you've got to remember this guy,
he's one of the most spectacular kickboxing records ever.
Yeah,
I mean,
what is it like 57 and oh or something like that and kickboxing and then he gets
into MMA and you know,
he loses to Matt Brown,
he gets kind of beat up on the ground,
comes back,
has some really good fights and you know,
it's been in there with world class fighters and beaten some world class
fighters.
But he's also,
I want to say he's 34 35 right.
And that was a lot of fights,
although we didn't get until recently until those three examples,
he had really get hit all that much.
But it's still the wearable tech Stephen Thompson
find out how wonderful it is.
It might even be 35 yep.
The hips and the knees and the shoulders and that whole five 35.
Yeah.
Um,
but,
and there's also that what he,
I mean he developed mastery in what he does.
Yeah.
And once you've developed that elite,
elite top level of reached your highest potential,
it's hard to keep going.
And then the masses start to close that distance though the general young kid
start,
you know,
a kid at Tristar,
like some of their young guys,
they have that and they've had Thompson in there for years and for us has been
able to study people like that up close and they all studied Leo Odo.
Now the young guy can do a lot of those things at a much higher level than
fighters that came before them.
So your level of mastery starts,
you plateau to a point that it's hard to go beyond.
It's,
it's really hard work and sometimes it requires you to get a little shittier for
a bit too to go past that plateau to weekend or get worse by having to reexamine
what you believe and the way that you train or the way that you fight to break
through a plateau.
You've got to kind of be willing to go backwards a bit.
And when you're fighting Tyron Woodley's of the world,
you cannot go backwards.
So it's kind of kind of stalls you there.
So,
but ultimately the big question also is,
is there some other strategy that hasn't yet been done that is a Stephen
Thompson beater and that low leg kick?
You talked about that mate.
So I cannot get to you.
So what would I prefer when I'm fighting Stephen Thompson body lock.
If I can get to the body lock cover up and down to get to a body,
like I got to touch them.
That's really hard.
He stops me from doing that or I got to hit him or kick him.
But when I do that,
he moves away and hits.
What if I can just get to the edge of his sort of bubble of,
of,
of hot,
that hot range where he can hurt you.
And maybe that low leg kick is a part of that,
you know,
maybe that low leg kick,
just getting on the outside of it where you're still somewhat safe,
but you can smash him up a little bit.
Maybe those are a weapon that hasn't been used.
Well it's,
this is also arguably the best striker that wonder boys ever faced in MMA,
arguably,
right?
I mean Moskva is very talented striker as well.
Uh,
but Wonderboy is a master of that front leg and that front leg is a real tricky
one.
Cause the,
that karate style that he uses,
he keeps his hands down low.
He stands totally sideways on you and you got to get past that front leg side
kick and Johnny couldn't get past it.
Hendricks got lit up by that front leg,
side kick and then front roundhouse kick to the face right afterwards.
It's just,
there's a lot going on with that front leg if you're not used to that.
And then if you,
if he'd get too obsessed with it,
the back leg comes.
Yeah.
Till is a way better.
He's a way better master of distance.
He understands distance and strike and he knows how to close that distance with
explosive power.
Very interesting.
Cause and before he fought cowboy,
his successes were fighting at distance and smashing guys who came in.
So he does do that.
He does by doing it,
you understand it on a different level,
you connect to it.
It is it in a mood tie way.
Whereas Wonderboy doesn't the cry way and Wonderboy is fantastic at moving his
waist back and forth like a snake and jumped on.
He's really good at that too.
Yes.
Tony Ferguson's really fucking good.
Yeah.
And that,
so w when I get to go study,
um,
Sanda and Kung Fu and you,
there are,
some of my friends are like,
well,
you know,
like enjoy it.
I'm like,
Nah,
this is going to be some brilliant shit to learn over here.
This and some of that long fist stuff.
Like people will often say,
well,
Kung Fu is not super relevant.
Some of that long fist reaching where I move my body through space to reach you,
which people would say is dangerous,
you get counted.
Well I check the answer is don't get countered.
The answer isn't discard a valuable weapons.
And so you see some of that.
Tony does that stuff really,
really,
really well.
A lot of really cool.
He does see him work with the wing Chung cool man wing chunk too.
When I'm sitting in your guard wanting to beat you up.
Tell me that.
Isn't wing Chung just were attached.
That's what that is.
That's what that is,
right?
Yeah.
I mean there's techniques in every single art that are like an established
realistic art that are valuable.
You know,
and there's,
there's gotta be something in wing Chung the people are missing for sure.
For sure.
Santa,
I mean art's psych that people would look at and Mike Discard because they would
think they're limited to only this scenario.
Well that scenario happens if I'm in your garden,
I want to fight.
We are,
that's that scenario.
So that thing may not be useful to fight,
you know,
Frank Mir.
But that thing will be useful in a context when you're fighting.
Well,
how about Jon Jones?
His use of you grab his wrist and he comes over the top of an elbow that is hand
tramping.
Yeah,
for sure.
I mean it really wasn't is what it is.
Leverage a Sherif.
Oh Yeah,
limb distraction.
Yup.
That's old school.
The structure.
Yeah.
How and
why that hasn't been rabid hauled a lot more,
although he's do start to see that and that moment where were,
you know,
I get to all four,
I get to four points that I'm going to stand up and you just kind of decide,
okay.
That's all right.
We'll get back to the fence in that process of standing up,
a lot of guys throw a fight,
finishing kick there or just at least take that chance to smash your leg with
one.
Like there's free shots that exist in these moments and Jon Jones is a master of
finding them.
He really is.
Yeah.
I hope they figure out what the fuck they're going to do with him soon.
I don't know where they stand now in terms of like his suspension or what have
you,
but here's my ultimate goal,
my hope,
my dream is that core me a fight,
Steve Bay for the heavyweight title and somewhere around then they announce when
Jon Jones,
the suspension is up,
they announced John Jones versus Brock Lesnar.
Love it.
I love it.
I just,
I mean look at their body types and look at what they are and where did they
come from.
I mean,
I love it,
but I know you've sat down with John and and stuff,
but what did you like,
what did he feel like you do you know what I mean?
Like what,
what Reed did you get from him?
Did you feel like he was saying the things that he thought you wanted to hear or
did you feel he was being honest and genuine?
Definitely both.
Easy and honest.
And he's also had some things that he planned out.
I like John a lot.
I really love that guy,
but I think he surrounds himself with a bunch of knuckleheads.
I think he's,
he's around too many people that are a bad influence.
And I think he's,
he's a wild man.
And I think when he's a wild man around other people that are sort of indulging
that stuff with them,
this is the word that I get,
not just from what I know,
but from the people that know him very well is that he's just around the wrong
people.
You know,
he's got bad influences.
I mean,
if you can identify that,
then you must change it.
Yet it's not,
it's not to take any personal responsibility away from him either,
because I'm sure he also makes for a bad influence to them.
Right.
I mean,
I'm,
the fucking baddest man on the planet can live like this.
I'll live like this to fuck it.
Let's do more coke and know it's what's party harder.
Let's drive fast.
Let's go drunk.
Um,
I don't know.
You know,
I don't know what the answer is.
We're,
we're a guy like John,
you know,
I really don't know.
I mean,
it's a,
it's got to have that come to Jesus moment.
Yeah.
Or not.
You know,
maybe he just keeps doing what he's doing and keeps beating everybody's ass and
people keep forgiving them and hopefully it doesn't wind up in jail.
But he should for sure get a driver for sure.
Get someone to fucking drive him around.
That's a bad,
that's a good bandaid.
But it's not going to be,
that's not the problem solver.
The truth is I think,
I mean we get to live the life that we want.
Like we get to choose the things that we do.
Like we have free to a certain extent to a certain extent.
I know freewill is something that's been deceived,
discussed and it's,
it's a fascinating concept,
but to some degree,
you know,
we are offering own lives,
and,
and if it isn't going the way that you want it,
small tiny changes can push it a different way.
Yeah.
It's a matter of whether or not he's willing to make those changes.
And you know,
right now I'm sure he just wants to get his license back,
you know?
But like when I see him like having these battles back and forth with chuck
Ladell Online,
like you got a bark away from that.
Like Chuck Odell,
some old warrior who is clearly taking too many shots like,
and you know the s you know,
calling him an old man and saying all this stuff and it's like just be the
better man in this situation.
You're,
you're the top of the heap right now at the top of your game.
You don't want some young guy doing this to you 15 years from now talking to you
that way.
I mean,
this is the,
these are the dark days,
but when we turn the TV on,
I don't care if you watch CNN or Fox or CNBC or whatever,
or the NFL or hockey or fighting or whatever.
A lot of what we see is a bunch of heads who somebody has said you choose
different sides or they know that's what they should do.
And then they just argue and we watch it.
We're taught it,
we see it every single day,
all the time.
You crazy.
It drives me crazy and transmits to fighting the sports guy talk.
Yeah,
that drives me nuts when it comes to fighting because they have this sort of
robotic predetermined pattern of behavior that they apply to football and
baseball and I just feel like fighting is just more personal,
more intimate is there's more on the line,
there's more at stake.
It means more to me and when I see that dopey sports guide jock talk applied to
fighting,
it makes me angry.
It makes me angry too,
but for different reasons as well.
One is this,
this doesn't apply exactly as you said and the other one is the city of apply to
football or anything because it's ritualistic,
like it acts as if this show doesn't exist.
The reason it looks,
so we were talking about how things meanings change once upon a time.
That was a professional speaker.
Now that is a rehearsed over,
strategized,
constructed artificial speaker and in a world where someone watches the fucking
Joe Rogan podcast or goes on and sees Dwayne training guys or watches a
supermodel on Instagram or sees what the rock is cooking.
Like I said,
we see real people everywhere.
So now this becomes ritualistic and artificial.
It's a strip club Dj to hey come into the top stage.
It's like that pre determined sort of pattern of behavior.
The they adopt this pattern and you know,
there's a lot of people that adopt that sports guy pattern and there's a lot of
shitty writers that do it too.
And they apply that insulting style of writing to combat sports.
And some of them have never been inside a cage and most in life and apparently
even trained.
Yeah,
no it,
it,
it's,
if you,
if you have not been kicked
in the fucking head in front of your mother,
you have no right to criticize.
Never saw me fight my mom.
I fucking got got God.
I got,
I wouldn't want that pressure.
A couple of punches happening and I get caught in the guillotine and I'm
thinking I'm okay and I'm driving my shoulder in and then I start to go out and
I'm just,
and I kind of hit him in the eye tap and I look up and my mom is right fucking
there.
She's right there.
And my mom.
My family is wonderful,
right?
Like I got the best wife that the humans have ever had in my parents and her
parents.
I'm surrounded by great people and I know that my mother literally was looking
at me like,
I'm proud of you.
You know,
don't worry,
this happens,
but my memory has are going
well.
She's probably just sad.
Yeah,
sure.
She's going to shake her head.
Yes,
it was.
Yeah,
but I mean if you haven't been to that,
if you haven't experienced failure,
if you haven't been carried out on a stretcher as everybody booze you or it felt
victory or been terrified,
you cannot logically criticized them because you don't understand the thing.
If you haven't done it,
if you have some respect for it,
I'll respect you.
Just just understand what they're going through like you.
I don't think you necessarily have to have gone to war to be a war
correspondent,
to understand it,
to talk about it.
You don't have to have shot someone to be able to understand what people are
going through or at least try to comprehend it,
but have some respect about it.
There's a way to criticize technique and movement without being insulting.
And I think this is a part of the problem with this.
The sports guy attitude isn't insulting attitude.
It's a judgmental one.
Yeah.
It's judgmental and mocking and I think they played a Johnny lunchbox.
I think they play to dumb dumbs and I just that it really hurts my feelings when
I see that sort of strategy applied to covering mixed martial arts.
Yeah.
And like I said,
it acts as if as less and less people consume this older but valid,
um,
uh,
interface television less and less and more and more are consuming other things
that are different and new and,
and stuff.
It's bizarre that the old one starts to say,
yeah,
well we still do it this way.
Right.
You can't do it that way because people now it looks weird and old now it looks,
it's context has changed because we have seen thousands,
we've seen what Michael Chandler eight today and how he helped his son and this
guy is saying,
well,
you know,
a striker versus grappler like,
and it's just,
you haven't evolved.
They,
yeah,
you have to step in and this applies to us all.
You have to reset up and look at where you are and what it's meaning is and
realize,
oh,
technology,
change the audience change the world changed my life,
changed the economy,
changed the market.
All of these things have changed.
I'm still the same.
I met,
I'm a dinosaur.
That doesn't make sense.
I can't do that.
I must change.
Right?
But the reason sports,
television,
the NFL or
many of these things,
news doesn't is it starts out that there are innovators.
So in fighting it was Dana White and the fatigue does and you guys and vital
young innovative creators and then as it grows you need organized thinkers.
You need people who can organize and structure something so that it can grow.
The problem is they get really good at structuring hierarchies that get really
good at structuring business in such a way that they are then in charge and then
when it changes,
you need those creatives again.
But the,
but these structure guys are there and they've built these formulas that they
are then bound by where it's like,
well,
of course we're going starting with the opening shot and then we're going to go,
we're right here in Brazil,
shot of the Christ,
the redeemer,
and then we'll go and here we've got a,
oh it's so unbelievable.
Matchup with the winner gets a title shot.
Those are rituals.
It was a bizarre formulaic rituals created when they mattered and there were
valuable by highly intelligent people that,
that were required to make this work.
But now you need different people,
you need a different thought,
you need crew,
the creatives back in and they usually don't want that.
Yeah.
I think,
uh,
I like your point about different approaches and I think one of the best ways to
maybe perhaps have a different approach is to have more intense coverage of
training footage.
You know,
and I think they're doing that with the embedded series of those online things.
I'd like more people to check those out.
I think if more people got an understanding of how much is involved in this,
like when people get injured and pull out a fight,
it's like some people will freak out and complain and write a bunch of stupid
shit.
Like I don't know what happened to Mirko Cro cop,
but you can't say anything bad about him,
but he's a superhero.
The Guy,
if that guy pulls out of a fight,
you've got to go.
Well,
he obviously must be too hurt to fight and this is part of the game,
you know?
I mean,
but I've read some ridiculous shit that people have said about Mirko online.
Like I went to Canelo's page the other day.
Oh my God,
there's pictures of Canelo Alvarez and people are,
you know,
judging his body and saying,
it looks tiny now.
And,
and there's all these emojis of pills and needles all throughout his entire
Instagram posts.
There's fucking,
the comments are ruthless.
Just ruthlessly fucking insult.
Dang.
I mean,
this is just the world we live in.
I did a breakdown on Vito and like you know,
he'd go in and then Instagram is the law,
at least in my experience is the least negative cause it's the newest.
What's the most top negatively youtube.
I agree.
Yeah,
because it's the oldest,
right?
It's the oldest because as things get older,
a lot of negativity is around and positive people leave positive.
People leave because they go on there on the early part of the technological
adoption life cycle,
positive people are innovators and early adopters and they go onto the newer
thing and then you leave behind the people who are negative and made the whole
place go septic and then that is argue with each other.
I wonder if that's the case I want,
I've never figured out
what is wrong with youtube comments,
but there are so ruthless like whenever I have a liberal woman on in particular
who you have on with an open mind and are interested in their perspective.
Some of them are my friends like Abby Martin when when she's on,
I don't even fucking touch those Commons or Whitney Whitney Cummings is on.
I don't mean I don't look at the comments period,
period,
but if I did,
those would be the last ones that I would look because Dave looked at them
before and like Whitney contracts in me and she's like,
what?
And the fuck.
And I was like,
don't read that shit.
It's like don't taste the poison.
Yeah.
If the,
wherever the positive people are,
if you're going to spend time.
And I like too,
because if 50,000 people watched me do a breakdown,
that means a lot to me.
Yeah.
And if 60 of them commented,
I'm gonna.
If I can schedule on the day 45 minutes,
I'm going to take the time and thank as many of them as I can,
but only where the good way only where the positive ones are.
Not that I want to be reinforced that what I'm doing right.
I'm not going to spend the time on people who are going through life so negative
that I can't get through to them anyways.
Right.
Somebody who's going through life looking for something and trying to to either
be inspired or learn something or by positive,
those are the people that you should spend time with.
And it's also like the reverse of giving candy to your kid when they're bad.
Yeah.
It's like don't go give those people candy when they're negative.
If you want them to get away from that,
you want their lives to get better,
which it will if they stop having that behavior.
Yeah.
Maybe of
from are just so broken.
They,
it's just like their structure is so poor.
The structure of their thinking is so poor and you know all a lot of them are
like shut-ins and does a lot of people with mental illness that are just
constantly commenting.
Yeah.
I mean and then there's the argument to like kill the comments,
but then people get furious at you.
We had an issue for a while and it was an accidental issue and the issue was
during the stream,
we don't allow the live chat because it was always like con to your mother's a
con like Horse Shit because people would just try to get attention.
If we read that stream while we were doing the show,
the show would be inexorably altered,
you know,
you'd,
you'd be altered by like what,
what,
what are you saying?
Don't say that.
Like you would read it and then that would be the show.
The show would be these people as well as you.
Well,
it's just not necessary or valuable because of the fact that we had the comments
killed during the live feed.
You couldn't,
you couldn't chat during the live feed when we would transfer it over to
youtube.
Um,
the comments would be disabled and people went crazy and the,
and I had a tweet about it,
but look,
I'm not disabling the comments.
I don't know what this glitches,
but they're gonna figure it out.
But Shab decided to disable his comments on purpose and do they fucking went
crazy and they were attacking him,
but what are the numbers that give a shit?
Like who,
have you ever commented a youtube video?
Have
you ever watched a youtube video and commented about it?
I don't think I ever have.
I never have either.
I don't know anybody worth a fuck that has that.
That's part of the problem is like I know there's some really positive comments
and people who were healthy people were just interested in debate and discussion
about particular topics,
but when you're dealing with all these negative people,
like what are the numbers?
If you have a million people watching a youtube video,
are we talking about a hundred people there?
Is it even if I don't even think it's the south 200 it might not even be a
hundred you might be dealing with like 30 cunts,
you know what I mean?
And they're the ones who are going to be mad that you disable the comments.
But does that really matter?
And it is.
This is keeping that,
that cesspool open,
keeping that commode open for them to dump their fucking verbal diarrhea into.
Is that really feeding the bay?
Is that giving the kid candy for being an asshole?
Is it the same?
Maybe.
Maybe I went,
saw you,
uh,
stand and talk to 600 people who came to your shell.
You had an in depth conversation,
chem trails,
this and fucking fighting that with each of them in the eye.
You spent for sure four hours when you took a bunch of friends out for dinner
and invited me,
which was really cool.
Anyway,
thank you.
I Brag about it,
all of that.
Uh,
and then I saw you walk across.
That was four hours for sure.
Okay.
Two to four hours.
I don't know the exact number.
Then I see you walk across the casino and in that time you do it again for
another half hour as you know,
Joey Diaz.
Oh.
You know,
like,
and then we sit down and somebody comes over as soon as you sit down and they
say,
Hey,
can I get,
and you'd go,
fuck off man,
I'm meeting.
That's the guy who will tell the world,
Joe Rogan's and Asshole,
that guy say fuck off whenever.
Yeah,
I can't,
you can't just stop your meal every time someone comes over 800 inter like human
deep interactions,
meaningful interactions,
that one can fuck off.
Well,
I don't want to say fuck off.
I just think that people have this distorted idea of space that they should just
be able to invade your space where you literally have a mouthful of food.
And I mean,
I've had it happen.
I've had,
it happened when I was feeding my daughter,
have her in my lap.
He'll be a cog in a selfie and you definitely can't get a selfie right now while
I'm feeding my daughter.
Get the fuck Outta here,
man.
That's just a misunderstanding of,
of space.
Yeah.
And
there it is a strange thing.
I mean,
I didn't watch my wife,
uh,
was asking me because I was in Singapore.
If I watched the,
um,
the royal wedding,
I'm like,
Nah,
fuck,
understand that at all.
I don't understand the motivation for doing it.
I don't even want to get it too.
But those are still humans.
Like those are still people there and that's the,
people don't understand that woman shit.
She does it this way here.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
They just,
they're,
they're people.
And can you imagine if the person asks you what you're feeding your daughter?
Somebody did that.
Maybe the first time he'd be like,
well,
I can't believe it's good once took a selfie with me,
but after that it would be,
it's still living your human life.
The only one you have,
you just can't interrupt
people while they're sitting at dinner with their family or with their friends.
They're just sitting there cutting food.
It's just like they don't owe you that,
like can,
you shouldn't ask for that.
It's just not the way to do it.
It's just not,
and you've got to know when people can't stop.
They just can't just say hi.
Can you just say hi?
Yeah.
No one can say hi.
Everybody wants to dress up their Facebook.
Everyone needs that fucking selfie.
It's just like,
Eh,
we're,
we're in a weird space with that stuff that,
that whole social media shit,
because people want something from you that they get up to.
It's not just their fam and they want to say hi,
they want something from you to make them look cooler.
And it's like you can give them some currency.
It's like you're a Pokemon and they can pick you up and
get a point for,
it's weird.
It,
um,
so I,
I told you,
I was saying,
Oh shit for breezy over doom got flat and he was just going to fight in Russia,
I think against all neck.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yup.
Well that's not how,
that's a wrap.
That's a wrap on that.
Well,
he's 40 years old trying to compete in something that's a young man's game.
That's the thing.
It's like you can get mad,
you can get outraged and that's a reasonable result or reasonable response if
you want.
But if you rationalize,
if you have empathy,
it's like this guy still wants to do this thing that his body won't allow him to
do.
And so he's willing to bend the rules to attempt it.
He failed and now he's going to have to pay the cost.
Francis.
Yeah.
It's a month after his knock out.
Lost a Volkov.
Right.
Volkov fuck tomorrow among jurors.
That guy's fucking dangerous.
Big,
long,
tall knockout artist.
The heavyweight thing is a whole other thing.
The thing man.
And when you get these seven footers that can kick ass like Volkov.
That's a fucking nightmare.
What does he like?
He's at least six 11
right.
Scary.
What crops?
How tall he is.
He's a big guys,
bigger than than doing by a lot of,
call it six,
six,
seven,
somewhere in that range.
Right.
Or doom.
Six Four.
Right.
Somewhere around that.
And have you ever met Brett Rogers who's Brett Rogers Rogers and now Brett
Rogers fought,
uh,
Brett grim.
Rogers.
Yeah.
But that guy,
that's the biggest person I've ever really,
yeah,
like I don't know what it was about his frame,
but I was trying to interview and it's only six,
nine or six,
eight or something.
But it was the physical frame of him and I was just like,
it was so wild as a triple h in a restaurant one time and I was like,
whoa,
like giant dude.
He's,
he's big,
big athletes like this.
Like what the,
the force that they can generate like in Gannon,
that ability to,
to create that type of power and impact.
This is a crazy
picture of Afghanistan and extra professional basketball player and a god who
looks like a tiny person.
So weird.
It,
God,
it looks like I look what I stand next to him.
Not Quite as much contrast but pretty ridiculous.
But there it is.
Look at that.
I mean that's absurd.
Fucking crazy.
We just,
there's,
there's more always,
but I have a Chihuahua,
the Chihuahua and you have your dog,
you put them beside each other and you're like,
that can't be the same species.
I know.
It's weird.
Right?
Then humans are just like dogs and that way,
you know,
we vary so wildly size.
Yeah.
He listened to let's wrap this up.
Tell people where they can get your breakdowns and your MMA stuff.
If you're from Dublin,
Ireland,
I'm there doing my one man show June 22nd how often are you doing this?
I'm doing this will be the fifth I think there was one practice,
one sort of friends and family.
I learned a lot from it.
Then Winnipeg and London,
Ontario and I did cause I knew,
you know,
harmonic and they've got some good friends there that would be supportive and
that was good.
Then I sold out a little venue in Toronto and what really,
really well and then now Ireland,
so the 22nd and I'm in Ireland on my Instagram page you can click through,
but and John,
Kevin has got to be my guest.
Beautiful website.
It's coming up.
It literally could be coming up today or in the next couple of days.
I think it's Robin black,
mma.com and Robin black MMA on Twitter and Instagram and a,
if you follow me on Instagram,
I set out to do a hundred breakdowns in three months and I've done 118 months.
That's how you try to develop mastery.
You just gotta be prolific and trying to develop a great following.
You know,
it's awesome.
Appreciate your Brooks brothers.
Let's do it again,
please.
Robin Black Ladies and gentlemen.